e
thank you for for coming and waiting for
us I I apologize for being late um so we
just heard from representative Wier say
that um there may be some bills related
to these sections so let's let's try
today to to learn what's here and and uh
go through your requests and then but we
may not be able to act right now okay
very good all right commissioner thank
you for coming good afternoon I
understand we actually have three
Commissioners here that
right uh good afternoon if if I could as
an introduction uh I think I did last
time but uh I asked uh assistant
Commissioner crepo Adam kpo to come up
uh since he's been very involved with
this and obviously uh you saw last time
and are familiar with our chief
operating officer Susan Carlson so you
have a few
handouts uh one is a spreadsheet of the
changes uh being requested to House Bill
2 uh we were trying to there's a lot in
House Bill 2 that has our name on it as
you know so we were trying to make it
more digestible hopefully that works if
it doesn't you can blame Adam uh also
um the you know the L the the biggest
homework assignment we got last time if
you know memory reserves is where can
you displace uh General funds with with
either new or increased fees uh we have
a a spreadsheet also uh that does that
and you'll see should you desire to go
that way uh we see a uh a change to the
general funds of be able to reduce it by
five and a half um million dollars by by
tweaking some fees also and we're
prepared to talk to that certainly so
that's a banum number not an annual
number correct I see thank you yes as
you're well aware some fees obviously by
the time you you go for your session
approve them they start to kick in it's
really the second second half of the
bium and then uh I believe you have
which was done earlier uh a Redline
version of some of the the requested
changes the house bill to and at some
point we do also have a requested change
to House Bill one regarding with our
fishing game
um uh relationship uh under this bill so
so can you give us a big picture of
what's happening in sections two through
five sure you want to do this or yeah
yeah absolutely I brought up for a
reason so um for the record Adam kpo
assistant commissioner at the Department
of Environmental Services sections two
through five they um you you probably
heard a lot about in the governor's um
speech that they are going to be
realigning some of the state agencies to
uh make permitting a little bit quicker
uh they have a 60-day clock that they
want to try to get to and this is one of
the ways that they're attempting to do
that so part of this is hb1 part of this
is hb2 I'll I'll talk about both um hb1
moves currently four positions from
fishing game and it moves uh three three
positions from dncr
um we are we requested a technical
change to hb1 to move the correct
positions there was a technical issue
there um from dncr and we have one
today uh to reduce the number of
positions moving over from fishing game
from four to three and so um the the
idea here is for when developers have a
project and they need Dees permits um
often times they have to deal with
several state agencies including dncr
and fishing game currently uh the idea
is to consolidate this um to just a
One-Stop shop for those those types for
any developments that need Dees permits
um to De to to Dees and
so that's that's really what the change
is trying to accomplish it was a little
bit broader and the initial version of
hb2 was going to give us all of the
wildlife reviews part of the Technic the
the redlined amendment that you have
there is an attempt to narrow that a
little bit so that it would only be Dees
anything that needs a Dees permit would
and a do permit would need to come to us
for a wildlife review which currently is
at fishing game and an
nhb um which is natural heritage
database it's a it's a tool that looks
for threatening endangered species um
both plants and animals and so those
those folks would be housed at Dees as
well under this proposal and so that's
in a nutshell what 2 through five
sections 2 through five and 6 through 8
do um at a very high level so represent
M uh thank you m thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming in I'm you rattled
off a lot of numbers there and things I
just want to make sure I'm clear so what
the the proposal is to move four
positions from dncr to Dees uh four
positions from fishing game okay um
there's a technical correction that
we're going to be providing to only move
three because they will still be doing
reviews for other state agencies when
they when their permits are required
there and for federal agencies when they
need a a wildlife review um and then the
end the net for dncr would be two
positions in hb2 we are going to be
sorry where would those where would
those two positions go from d dncr to us
to Dees so you'd get three from fish
three from fishing game two from dncr
correct and then in hb2 there is a
position established as a supervisor
position and that will uh manage these
these additional positions we're getting
from these other agencies and it will be
sort of a uh we haven't decided on a
name yet but a you know an endangered
species uh unit within our land
resources management which is where Mo
most of our are issued out of and so
they would be interfacing with our staff
obviously they would be our staff if if
should this move forward but um they
would be able to interface every day
with our staff to ensure that these
these uh the coordination is there to
and would that be a new position that
supervisory position that would be a new
position and now I'm and and
so so hb1 assumes or no hp2 right
assumes that there'd be these seven POS
four position six positions moving and
one new position and what you're
proposing now is just having three
positions move a HB hb1 contemplates two
positions from
dncr and four positions from fishing
game we're providing technical
corrections to the committee that's so
that's hb1 yep hb2 separately
establishes the supervisor position
position it's a new okay that would be a
new position um currently these
positions don't uh several of them don't
have funding in the other agencies the
governor's budget proposes to use
General funds to pay for those positions
in the first part of the bium or uh over
the bium and then after this bium is
over then it would we're also increasing
fees in this proposal and that's further
down the list of uh on the spreadsheet
but we're increasing Wetlands fees by
50% and alteration of terrain fees are
going up 100% And I know the governor's
office and and us as well have worked
with uh the home builders and the
associate General Contractors and
several other groups to ensure that this
was something that they would be able to
do um and so we've we've worked with all
of those groups and they as long as they
get a tangible benefit from this type of
move um they they feel okay with with
fees increasing in those in in those uh
fees permits permit applications
so okay all right representative wer did
you calculate whether the new fees would
cover the cost of all these people they
yes they will they will cover the cost
um of of those people yes thank you
represent R thank you Mr chair um as far
as the fees go um they would these fee
increases the 50% the 100% would they
apply both to let's say individual
property owners who might want uh an
approve you know to improve their
property as well as commercial and
Industrial developers and companies so
they these would apply to all Wetlands
permits and alteration of terrain
permits alteration of terrain permits
those are typically commercial type
developments those are anything over
100,000 square ft uh of of impact and uh
unless you're in the protected Shoreland
then it's 50,000 square feet of impact
you know think long driveways and and
big developments like that uh Wetlands
you you may have some some uh small um
you know homeowners or or or Property
Owners but um but yeah it would it would
that would have an imp but we're not
proposing to increase Shoreland fees
which is different than Wetlands fees
and so that's so that's the distinction
there can I
follow um my concern with increasing the
fees for individual private homeowners
for both Wetlands is that it may or do
you think it it might encourage some
people to do work off permit because now
instead of paying $400 they're going to
$600 I I can't speak to the we haven't
raised those fees in some time um we'd
have to look back to see if compliance
you know if compliance went up you know
our compliance actions went up after the
last Fe increase I I don't know that
there's an indication that that would
happen I don't know if you if you have
any additional thoughts on that it's and
I don't remember the bill number so I'm
gonna actually it's in here right so so
we do have there is a correction in here
also for clarification house bill to
regarding so so usually even in that
that happen stance somebody's hiring
somebody to do this work right so we've
clarified in the in house bill 2 that if
if you're a contractor and you knowingly
violate this that you're liable also so
we think that will help that a lot right
so to the extent that I'm a homeowner
I'm going to hire a trade to do this and
the Tradesman knows I I'm I'm liable if
I do what I'm not supposed to do I we
think that will help make that not
happen to to the extent you're saying
right because it's not impossible a
homeowner could do some of this
themselves but by and large they're
they're Contracting out with people to
do this work and we think this would
help that a lot okay another followup so
with the wetlands permit how many of
those that are issued go to like that
private homeowner versus how many go to
larger
so this is Phil trobridge he runs the
land resource management Bureau uh he
has while he's getting ready here so he
he runs the wetlands program Shoreland
uh subsurface which is septic tanks and
uh alteration of terrain are all under
his bureau and
parenthetically should you go forth with
the governor's um initiative so with
those other positions from fishing game
and dncr they would all be housed under
his
his purview
okay you want me to repeat the question
uh I think I understand hello
representative thank you for the
question we have just done an analysis
of this and we think about from on the
wetlands permits maybe 30% are related
to something like housing as opposed to
larger other projects so it's not you
know most of the you know there's
different categories of wetlands permits
as you know you know for instance there
are Shoreline structure permits and
there are you know construction of
houses uh so our best guess is at about
50/50 related to projects that are done
by an individual home homeowner versus
some sort of commercial project okay 30%
and then um other question um of those
30% how many are permit by notification
and how relative to the other ones uh so
yeah permit by notification um is about
half of what we do um and then and uh
those are for those are for the smaller
projects uh and then their for standard
permits are the larger ones okay what
would what would you consider what would
your opinion be if there was a
two-tiered system so that private
homeowners with a singular project low
scale would not be subject to the in the
50% increase in
fee well so I guess one thing I'd add
here is that with a permit by
notification it's a flat fee it's just
whatever you're doing you get charged
$400 in this case the proposal would go
to
$600 for the larger projects it's a flat
fee plus an impact fee so already there
is a two-tier situation where the larger
projects you know depending on the level
of impact can be thousands of dollars of
fees as opposed to the $400 to $600 so I
think already with having the pbn fee
structure the way it is um we have that
type of two-tier approach um and uh
frankly from uh the representative wer
asked you know had we done the
calculation of do the fees would the
fees cover these positions um and you
know we would need the increase on all
the fees in order to make this work okay
does the fee cover do or does the
department do any followup on fees to
ensure that the conditions that were set
out in the permit or were
complied we do that we rely a lot on on
um the public to report to us potential
non-compliance in which we investigate
we investigate about 300 um complains a
year uh to determine whether uh work
representative wer I think there's
somebody who wanted to talk to you
okay so we're expecting like neighbors
to tell on neighbors that you know that
is a way that we've heard that tends to
be very effective um we also hope
through the online permitting systems
that we're putting into place to be able
to get more of our staff in the field as
well okay thank you thank you Mr chair
very good
so what is the responsibility or that
that F fishing game and dncr have now
that they're losing or no longer
responsible for whatever so currently
under our permits we require a the
applicant to get a nhb letter from dncr
that is basically describing at a high
level what they have on the site and and
what types of species are on there
whether it's a plant or an animal or or
habitat once they get that information
they work with uh the reviewers which is
what we're uh assuming
to um to come up with recommendations
that to mitigate that uh the impact to
those species and so that's the same for
both fishing game and and dncr and then
we incorporate those recommendations
into our permits and so the The Hope
here is moving them all Under One Roof
Is that the coordination will happen
more
effectively um you know will'll be a
One-Stop shop so the applicants not
having to go to three or more agencies
it can it can be more depending on what
other types of permits they have but the
most common is are these three agencies
and we all work together very colle
collaboratively but at the end of the
day the applicant is responsible for
coordinating with all three separate
agencies to ensure that they're
upholding this their the statutory
responsibility under the law and so what
this is doing is it's consolidating that
bringing that re those you know running
the running the report the the letter
and um doing the reviews and Phil can
kind of speak to what some of the
nuances of of how we plan to implement
this should it pass but uh at a very
high level that's that's what these uh
agencies do so is it fishing game when
the species is an animal and the and
dncr when it's a plant or something like
that correct I see okay representative
eil well I just have so many questions I
don't know um I I don't know in what
order to ask this but I guess if if I
have a concern about this proposal it's
to understand the effect of this on dncr
and fishing game um because if I've
learned anything over the last several
years any individual person even if
their permits permits they might perform
other functions within the agency and if
you take an employee from say dncr and
put them with
de
dncr is losing a person that they might
be able to use in different ways and I'm
interested in your answer but at the
appropriate time Mr chair I'd be
interested to hear from dncr and fishing
game directly about what they think
about the program So based on my
conversations and and the the
commissioners of both those agencies are
here to to speak to that at the
appropriate time but my understanding is
for dncr the vast majority of what the
staff do uh involve these environmental
reviews currently and so we're we're
assuming those um
and I I would say that there wouldn't be
a huge impact to that Agency on the fish
and game side the reason why we have the
technical changes in hb2 in that Redline
amendment is because there are some
staff that do reviews for other state
agencies and uh also the federal
government when they have permits and
things of that things of that nature and
so that's why we're proposing to provide
one of the four back to uh fishing game
because they we realized throughout this
process that they do things other than
our permits um we when we spoke to them
the split is really around 30 7030 or so
and I'm sure they'll correct me on that
number but um just from a high level
that is around what what these POS you
know of the four positions around 70% or
Dees related
uh reviews and around 30% are other
types of reviews and so the we thought
the appropriate split was in instead of
all four you know they keep one of them
and then we would retain the other the
other three um and this is all in
coordination with the governor's office
of course so so are the people that
moving the people that go out in the
field and look for the animals and look
for the plants and discover that they're
there and that kind of thing or is it
that that is not uh their function their
function is primarily to do the the
reviews uh desktop analysis working with
the applicant on uh best best management
practices if there are any you know uh
the recommendations that they provide
for the specific species they coordinate
with the other biologists at their uh
Orbot nness at their respective agencies
and ensure that they're making the
appropriate recommendations and so all
of that will still occur it's just they
they will be Lo the the reviewers
themselves who make those and work on
those recommendations will be located at
Dees representative eil okay so just as
a followup to that um the other thing
that just really gives me heartburn
generally with permitting is that I want
to be sure that there's adequate staff
to process a permit request and it
doesn't simply become sort of a permit
by notification because you don't get
the permit out the door um in a timely
fashion and I I looked really closely at
the deadlines here and and I guess I
would
like like to think we would like some um
reassurance that the permits that are
submitted you've worked this out so that
you have adequate time to give it a full
and proper review so the 60-day timeline
is in this proposal however it's similar
to our permits right now where we have a
50 day timeline or uh you know in some
other cases a shorter timeline there is
the opportunity to work with the
applicant if we if we need a Time
extension we can do that and if we don't
have all of the information to make a
decision on a specific application and
we run up against that clock because the
applicant hasn't provided it then we
would we would deny deny the permit just
like we do with all of our other types
of permits we we obviously make sure
that we have all the information and
have the proper time to review and vet
whatever projects are in front of us
before we make it we we issue an
approval um and so it's the way it
structure is very similar to our other
types of permit permitting processes
there is an opportunity for extensions
and things of that nature and I will
just comment that oftentimes the reason
why I mean you may have heard from some
of your constituents sometime every once
in a while one of these things do take a
significant amount of time and the re
sometimes the reason for that is because
the applicant has had a request for
information for a significant amount of
time and sent it you know they may have
it for a few months and then respond to
us after a few months after we sent it
and so um and and they consider that
time that they have the balls in their
coure as part of the time that Dees is
reviewing it and I I think we see that
very differently than than applicants um
and so that's what that is trying to
address so right represent well he had
one more comment it's I think an
important Point too is the governor's
initiative with these fee increases you
know again we're back to fee for service
as we discussed last time provides a
stable Revenue source for not only our
existing staff but the staff that we
would be bringing over to ensure that
this type of review can happen properly
and you know in the past has been arpa
money and you know Etc so that's an
important consideration too is that that
stable shity of funding also uh to me
goes a long way if well I I appreciate
the reassurance I just kind of want to
hear you guys say it um and then the
other thing is um it says that you're
going to change the well there's a
permit by notification uh provision now
for areas of less than 150,000 square
feet so that's a change from the current
law which is what a I don't remember I
just was curious about that yeah so the
current law States it's 100 thou
anything over 100,000 square feet
requires an alteration of terrain
permitting review they need to submit an
application and we need to review it and
either approve or deny the permit uh
what this is proposing to do is create a
permit by notification process between
100,000 square fet and 150,000 square
fet and that's around 15 to 20% of the
reviews depending on the year that we
get and and the r there's a similar bill
Senate Bill 110 that is going through
the Senate currently it we we are
proposing to have the language we have a
technical correction uh in that Redline
packet that that you have that would
propose that that be that mirror Senate
Bill 110 because it has some some better
language in there and all basically all
this is doing it's giving us rule making
ability to create a permit by
notification between those two
thresholds right so people just have to
feel comfortable with that extra 50,000
thank you okay representative R thank
you Mr chair I'm looking at your sheet
that you had um for uh potential
increases to offset funds uh the
response to committee requests for fee
increases so we we've talked about fees
but what about fines how much revenue
does the department generate a year in
fines and is there opportunity there to
maybe increase fines that um are issued
when there are
violations I would say most of our fines
currently go to the general fund um one
of the arguments for that is in the past
by especially in the legislature has
been they don't want us to set quotas or
that have some sort of system like that
that
incentivizes um you know go going after
people uh for for arbitr you know small
violations things that they can't be
worked out um obviously we take our
responsibility very seriously on
enforcing the law and ensuring that any
violations that occur that we learn
about get remediated but that current
most fines and fe uh fines currently go
in violation uh Revenue go to the go to
the general fund how how much is that do
um no um um it varies greatly year toe
um we set a budget of about $75,000 for
fines and it could be um lower than that
or it could be several hundred thousand
it just depends on what cases get
settled
when
okay because I
mean from my perspective it's okay if it
goes to the general fund um I'm just
wondering
if my my concern is we may be missing a
lot of violations um um and that's not
just to um have a consequence for people
violating their permit but also um that
revenue is probably going to could be
used for mitigation or other programs
damage that was caused by the
violation so um that's something I I
mean if it there it's just an area I
think I mean we look at fines for a
whole bunch of other
departments uh we look at it you know in
the court system or way of defraying
costs um um I just think it's an area
that in that we need to look at in
addition to fees because it is it is a
revenue and we should get a handle on
the revenue that is um being I guess the
Services we don't get right so one of
the things that we do do is we often you
know settle with with uh violators of
whether it's Shoreland or other
um other parts of the statue to
remediate and and uh maybe have some
conser you know put some land in
conservation or work with them on other
types of consequences as well um and and
and sometimes that includes you know
paying a fine sometimes that in includes
um not paying the fine if they have a
substantial um you know if they put some
substantial land in preservation or
something like that um but I I I hear
what you're saying
and and to do uh significant you know
significant enforcement I think you know
you'd be looking at some more staff too
um at that point but I I just throw that
out there representative Ms thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking um my question
um is there any um redundancy in the um
in the in the rsas that you're going to
be inheriting from these other agencies
and I guess what I'm getting at is
um is there you know I think what we
would want to avoid is a situation where
you're filling out two reports that are
essentially similar but that's because
that's specified in the RSA I mean is
there are there changes that need to be
made in the rsas to allow you to be as
possible thank you for the question uh
um I think the short answer is no I
think we've looked at this pretty
carefully and we're we're taking a
pretty small piece of the existing
rsas that would be needed relative to
our permitting programs um but the the
rest of the authorities um for
implementing the RSA would would reside
with the NCR and fishing game you know
just not the permitting
part I I think also the the the hope for
the Governor's initiative uh is to kind
of have One-Stop shopping one one uh
belly button to push so to speak if I'm
rather than having to talk to three
agencies per
se they they know where to go and then
can be the work can be done in that
fashion so that that's the hope is is to
instead of having multiple it would be
one place to go but I I agree with you
completely I mean I think that that that
should be the goal I guess what I was
concerned about was that you know okay
the applicant is going to one place but
you know after the applicant talks
there's somebody that's still having to
do three different things send them to
three different places that you know
maybe he's not necessary and and I don't
know maybe it is necessary but uh can
you know how do we streamline it to make
it easier for your
folks I think I think we we really
looked at this and you know from from
the perspective of streamlining there
there really wouldn't be a whole lot of
redundancy you know we're let's say we
have 20 people that work on this the the
way we're looking at this is we're
taking you know five of those 20 people
and moving them to our agency but it's
going to still be the same 20 people
working on it just maybe more efficient
for the applicant and on our end to have
them at in this physical location of our
building to be able to do this work and
so I I I don't think there would be any
redundancy a lot of this a lot of the
same things would happen it would just a
lot of it would be streamlined because
you'd be talking to one agency instead
of three
so go ahead all right just one one more
followup and it's it's somewhat related
um in the in the red line that you gave
us um says rule making shall commence
within 180 days and I'm not that
familiar with the rul making process but
um is there any reason it can't happen
sooner I mean one of the reasons the
governor is proposing this is to you
know help jump start what we need to do
in the housing
area it it will happen sooner we just
wanted to give sufficient time to be
able to work with stakeholders get as
you may be aware um and certainly the
members of JL car are are probably
painfully aware but it does take a
significant amount of time to come up
with a concrete proposal that meets the
letter of the law and factors in all of
the stakeholder input that we want to
get for this and ensure that we do it
what I'd hate to do is is do it fast and
not get not get it right and and I think
what what we're proposing here is to
have a little bit more more time and I
can assure you we're going to move
faster than 180 days but we wanted to
give ourselves a little bit more time to
to be able to get to JL car and Factor
all of that stuff in um and so that's
that's the reason why we're we're
proposing
that so one thing that would help me is
give me a a sort of Soup To Nuts example
somebody has a piece of rural property
and they want to build a building there
does do do they call on fishing game to
say come out and look around for any
endangered animals and they call dncr
come out and look around for any
endangered plants let me know what's
there and then I go to you guys and say
I plan to do such and such or how does
that work thank thank you for the
question so there are quite a few
generous land owners Property Owners
members of the public that report to
it's it's the natural heritage database
uh whether or not there's a a rare plant
on their property or uh threatened or
endangered species on their property or
anything else like that their habitat um
there are certainly Folks at fishing
game and dncr that go out in the field
too to confirm those things um but Soup
To Nuts an applicant they have a project
that they're proposing uh what we've
always encourage folks to do is get
their letter from the natural heritage
database so that's the reviewers that
we're we're taking on looking at the
database to see if there are any
threatened or endangered plan or animals
on or near the property or their
habitat from there they work uh with the
staff that will be moving to come up
with
recommendations and those get
incorporated into our permit um but that
process can take a significant amount of
time depending on the complexity of the
species that they're working with so
they'll get this letter then they'll
have several meetings with fishing game
um
dncr and come up with recommendations
that uh need to be incorporated into the
permit to ensure that we don't endanger
uh or appreciably jeopardize the uh the
continued existence of the species and
that's how the the the law is written
and so once that is done we the
applicant is then required to come to us
for a permit sometimes these things
happen concurrently sometimes they don't
happen concurrently they come to us for
a permit we do our review and then we
will incorporate those recommendations
into our our permit so it would be a
condition as part of our permit and uh
Phil lives this day dayto day so I don't
know if you have anything you want to
add to that but that's from a Soup To
Nuts process that's basically how it
work sure I think the only thing I would
add is um what we ask someone to do when
they are applying for a permit and we
have these requirements in our in our
rules is that they do this uh review or
check in the DAT with this natural
heritage database and if that check does
not uncover any
reports of you know threatened
endangered species in that vicinity uh
they move on there's no further work
they need to do on the wildlife side uh
and they come to us and we do our
permitting um so but if there there is
An Occurrence then there's a process by
which these people you know these
reviewers are taking a look at it and
saying is this an old review is this an
old report is it a something that that
is for example what we call a hit but no
impact in which case um we could you
know there's really no further work
that's needed uh one of the things that
we'd like to do with this program is is
identify kind of a high medium and low
category during that review because I
think it's important for applicants to
understand when maybe they're looking at
a very sensitive site and then before
they get too much invested in it and
they understand that it's going to be
challenging for permitting um and that's
often the challenge for us is someone
has in you know gone in two years of
planning maybe invested a considerable
amount and then they find out that this
is a site that's going to be very hard
to develop uh so we think some work on
the front end here when they're doing
this these data Check reviews where they
can get an early indication of high
medium and low um would really help
improve the process so people can do
that right now they can look at a piece
of property and and look in this
database all on their own correct yes
well they I should I should say that it
kind of works in a way it's a a
combination database and um human review
uh you know they're putting in
information to say this is the parcel
that I'd like to develop uh that
generates um basically a work order or a
work ticket for people in the natural
heritage Bureau and Fish and Game to
then look at the results that are NE
near that area uh and so there's they're
using their expert knowledge of the you
know the types of records that were
returned and the age of them and what
they know about the area to say what do
we tell this person do we tell them it's
it's a no no violation or no no concern
in this area or yes you need to come
into us and get a recommendations and
those people are staying at that that
would be the group that would be coming
to
Dees oh okay and I think and so in that
way there's be some good integration
with what we do when we work with other
applicants for pre-application views
giving them a heads up as to what we
would consider to be issues regarding
Wetlands permitting or Shoreland
permitting is are there fees for that
part or not there's a there's a fee
right now of $25 to do that data check
review I see uh in The hb2 Proposal uh
that fee would be increased to
$50 um and you know it's you can see
that it's it's more than just a database
ping there's people behind the scenes
who are doing you know a little mini
review yeah right and so that's where we
think because we have these experts able
to review these things we could
implement this high medium and low
categorization and would the $50 cover
both the plant and animal parts yes
right now it's it's combined data
database for Flora and Fauna gotcha okay
very good other questions represent
thank you Mr chair I want to go back to
the Fine thing so um I believe Susan you
said that the department budgets about
$75,000 for Fine Collection um is there
someone and I I tried to find it in HBO
I couldn't see it is there a person
whose responsibility is in is
enforcement in
Dees so we we yeah in the land resources
management section yes I mean for for
are different divisions and different
programs within the agency there's not
one singular person that's that's
respons responsible for enforcement so
if it's a solid waste violation uh folks
in Sol compliance staff in solid waste
would handle that if it's a land
resources management issue which is
those four buckets subsurface which is
septic systems alteration of terrain uh
Shoreland and wetlands those there is a
a unit within that group for compliance
and enforcement and that and so those
folks handle those so but it really
depends on the the the section of the
agency that you're working in and but
and they're they're the closest to it
because they're the experts in those
specific rsas and the rules behind those
rsas and so uh to I think I don't know
if that answered your question but there
There's No One Singular person in the
entire agency that's responsible for
coordinating enforcement so yeah I guess
my concern is that the amount of fines
budgeted Don't Come Close I guess to the
the the budget to support that to to
support and enforcement so for instance
let's say if you had a a person or group
of people and you figure maybe the cost
of enforcement for their salary and
benefits and you know ancillary costs
might be let's say 300,000 you're not
nearly covering that with the $75,000
budget okay thank you all right so
should we hear from fishing game and and
dncr to see if uh there's any objections
to any of this before we before we get
into the details of
version hello
hi
[Music]
hello Sarah Stewart commissioner of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources thank you for um asking for
our thoughts and feelings um that's you
know you're known for that at division
one thoughts and feelings um we've had a
lot of conversations uh with Dees um
with my staff uh I brought director
Patrick Hackley from forest and lands um
his bureau chief for the uh natural
heritage Bureau um I feel confident that
we can proceed with the with the plan as
Dees outlined um and you know we support
the mission to create efficiency um and
and are willing Partners to do whatever
we can to achieve that goal so just for
you we heard that two positions are
moving to Dees but then we've also heard
maybe four positions so is there so two
things going on yeah so originally um
before we got into the weeds um there
was the thought to include two people
from the um division of historical
resources as well and after examining
sort of the the end goal of this um
change it was unanimously decided that
that wouldn't help create efficiencies
um and so we amended that okay and I
assume these are two filled positions
yeah yeah okay good h
good afternoon thank you Stephanie Simi
executive director for New Hampshire
fishing game I appreciate you all asking
us to come up here um as Sarah said uh
fishing game we are supportive of the
governor's initiative and desire to
streamline government efficiencies I'm
trying to do that myself as a new
director for an agency uh so I'm fully
100% behind that effort and as she also
mentioned that we have been working
closely with Dees and Dancer Department
of Natural and cultural resources to
ensure that we could um make this a
successful transition uh uh honestly it
does impact our agency probably more
significantly than the others but um I
think that we are finding a me median
ground that we can try to sustain what
we need to do uh many of the uh ideas
that we've been you've heard from the
team from dees are ideas that we had
been talking about prior to this
initiative as far as like um the data
check tool and in high you know creating
a high of sensitivity those sorts of
things but um you know admittedly from
my position we did an analysis and it's
really about 1.5 people that we need to
continue for our permitting uh reviews
outside of Dees but in order to make
sure that we have efficiency and success
on that end we can get by with the one
person and we'll we'll see how it goes
um you know I may be coming back to my
own house Division and asking for some
other support but nonetheless we're
we're trying to to make this work we
want it to be successful um we 100%
agree with the One-Stop shop um you know
obviously I am concerned about how it
affects our agency and in doing the
other permitting or not permitting
excuse me the environmental review that
is required of our agency uh we do
environmental review not just for uh
federal agencies but also for nonprofits
that are getting federal grants and we
provide that technical uh review because
our mandate is Fish and Wildlife
Resources and ensuring that there's no
impact to those so is the database they
talked about is that very accurate and
and can you really tell on this piece of
land that there are certain animals
living there and others that aren't and
things like that it is very it's it's a
good start it is very it's a very good
foundation to start from uh that does
vary by project uh some of the concerns
about different projects and what's
being proposed during a project can
impact species differently um the type
of species is important you know
particularly if you need to do surveys
it creates a delay in some of the work
so uh I think if we can we we be working
with Dees for developing best management
practices and trying to help develop a
high-grading system I think that we can
get there uh the data is not only just
the public input and such it's also it's
fishing games data we are inputting data
into that system so as we're doing
surveys as we're doing research we're
updating that database as best as we can
with with the materials that we get and
even Sarah's team is doing the same so
when your officers are out there
somewhere and they say oh I saw such and
such they come back and change the
database to yes mostly it's our
biologists that are actually doing some
field field census work but yes it's our
staff across the board that are helping
to update that thank you welcome to
division one thank you I know I get the
best of both
worlds um not being as familiar with
your budget as as others might be what
is the source of funds for the
employee employees so right now this is
an excellent question thank you very
much for asking that so right now they
are funded through arpa which goes away
in December so this transition that
we're talking about it all if they all
go to Dees obviously they're going to
need funding to support them if one
remains with us we are going to need
funding to support that position because
there is not it's a temporary position
at this point point and it was only
funded through the arpa funding so I
will if it stays with us I will be going
back to house division 2 asking for the
consideration of General funds for that
support but this whole endangered
species thing is not new right no it's
not new it's just escalated uh we have a
lot more projects a lot more uh
sensitivities and I will mention also
our environmental reiew is not just
limited to um threatening danger species
it's also about you know water quality
and water flow so that we have good
healthy fish you know fish uh e
ecosystems and things like that there
are a variety of things that go into the
environmental review process on our end
the permitting end is a little different
right so I see okay representative EV
well it's just um I I definitely don't
know the whole history here but I think
that fish and game generally had been
really struggling with permitting and
then through arpa they had given you
four more people to try to improve the
process and you were sort of chugging
along and now we're rearranging things a
little bit so um I guess
it I'm thinking my original question if
we're really trying to streamline this
process and do better with permitting
across the three agencies it's just
really important that in taking this
look we give adequate funding and
Staffing not just for the agencies from
their end but for the people that are
trying to work it through and I just I
Adam you referred to this earlier I know
a lot of people are frustrated with the
delays and the response and I don't
blame the agencies I blame the Staffing
situation so I hope division two is kind
to you thank you thank you yes I I would
agree with you I think we I think I
although I was not here from what I have
gathered from the my in my investigation
of this whole situation is that yes we
did lack from staffing issues um we also
weren't uh at a point where we were
raising any fees to cover that Staffing
if that was a a potential option the
other thing I think that we may have
struggled with and I I think this is
where I I support what DS is is trying
to propose here is that we tried to work
through the process with the applicant
rather than just saying at this point if
we don't hear back from you it's a
denial so that I think created a lot
long history of working for months and
months and months when maybe we should
have just said no we don't have the
information from you it's a denial at
this point and you'll have to just come
back um so that it's a different
approach but I think it might help get
everybody back on starting a good
starting point and understanding what's
expected of each other and how we're
going to work
together okay all right so commissioner
are there other dncr sections here in
house Bild 2 um I guess we've already
so I
don't do you have anything I don't think
so yeah Mr chair
okay all right great well then thank you
both for coming than chairman yes
representative Le I was trying to find
your name on the fish at game site but I
came up with all the directors but I
mean of the Commissioners but not your
newest director and I'm sorry I didn't
get your name when you my name is
Stephanie Simi Stephanie okay yes and
actually I've only just been added to
the site just like within the last week
and a half oh could you spell your last
name then s i m e k oh okay first name
Stephanie with a pH all right thank you
thank you very much all right thank you
come back again
sometime
okay all right any so I'm back to um
Dees and the sections 2 through five you
here this this red line
section representative McGuire yes can I
ask a question goad up them for the
environmental um scientist position I
noticed there's funding in hb2 is there
also fing in hb1 for that that's a
duplicate
correct okay so we'll division one will
need to remove the
appropriation for the environmental
scientist position from
hb2 from what from hb2 the environmental
hb1 I think it would be more appropriate
to leave it in the budget rather than
have it as an appropriation in
hb2 which which section are we talking
about um page seven uh section four
um Yes except there is
a when the positions were put in our
budget they were put in at 2080 hours
not
1950 so um we'll have to work on that
correction yeah yeah okay and I'm not
sure they are the same position I'm
trying to get the details on that as
well okay we can work offline on that
thank you okay you're talking about line
19 on page 7 yes yes okay all right good
so
um back to the redline
version so the redline version you'll
see in front of you you have um I should
have I I said sections two through five
but I should have uh numbered them in
the SE
section is that it um it changes it so
that currently under hb2 we would be
doing all of the reviews for any state
agency this what this is doing is it's
saying that uh other departments and
agencies who need to uh you know make
sure that projects don't appreciably
jeopardize the continued existence of a
species if they have uh staff internally
that can work on that then they can do
those in lie of working for fishing game
and so that the way that was the way we
uh figured that we could do that in that
paragraph so that's the intent
there um in paragraph 4 it is doing
similarly it's doing the same thing it
is narrowing it down to just RSA 482a
which is Wetlands uh
485a which is aot in uh 236 which is
driveway permits at do this was part of
a lot a lot of our projects also
required do driveway permits so that was
another they're roping them in into this
into this proposal that's a fourth
agency that sometimes developers need to
deal with and so um we would be doing
those reviews as
well um representative leechman
mentioned uh or representative Ms I
believe mentioned uh one changing it
from 30 days to 180 days that's also
happening in that paragraph can I just
stop so even though you're taking over
the do permits you feel like you could
do it with the Staffing that you've set
up at this that's correct we you're not
taking people from do for this one we we
are not taking people from do it's we're
not doing the driveway permits we're
doing the environmental reviews when a
developer goes and gets a driveway
permit um typically they would still
need to work with fishing game as well
on
that
um going down to paragraph five these
are just uh it's re re uh lettering if
you will and uh cleaning it up because
below the before paragraph 6 listed out
a bunch more statutes where this would
apply at Dees where it doesn't currently
apply and so we we changed that and
there was a duplicate in there as well
so we crossed that out um and so that
all of
paragraph uh five is attempting to do
the same thing um it's just it's just
rewarded to be more more approp
appropriately
worded and then the only change to
6 to 8 which is the dncr piece is also
days and then well let's let's go back
why is um Roman six being eliminated so
six so we're adding in
paragraph four we're adding those rsas
there was a duplicate in paragraph 6 and
then there was also they were going to
add Shoreland in there and that was a
that was a tech a technical mistake
currently Shoreland permits are
specifically not subject to these en
these environmental reviews oh I see and
so uh we're getting rid of that too so
but we're keeping the other three that
are in there and just moving it back to
a different paragraph
yeah we frequently get large numbers of
of pages in hb2 with all sorts of
reorganizations which troubles me as to
who initiates this process is it is it
the governor's budget person is it the
agency or well the alternative you could
have gone through the legislative
process so what who who initiated all
these changes so this this was
specifically a governor's office
proposal we worked with them heavily to
make sure that it would technically
work and obviously we're coming in with
this amendment because we didn't catch
everything initially uh as as you know
that when the new governor comes in they
have very little time to prepare their
changes to what the prior Governor um
creates and so there was a obviously we
were we were kind of Off to the Races to
get this done so we made some we we
didn't catch everything when we provided
them language and so this is an attempt
to fix some of those things at what
point were you contacted to about all
these changes
uh we were contacted we knew that this
was a priority for governor aot um we
were contacted uh about doing some sort
of initiative early on and then as time
developed and they they were trying to
formulate what they what what they
wanted to move forward with we were
contacted um sometime I believe at the
end of January I'd have to get you I
don't know the exact date okay and then
we'll likely have some input from the
legislators that deal with this area of
policy and they'll come to it and do
some more changes
so yes for the
Beast it's a lot of red lines yes I I uh
I apologize for the red lines but we
want to make sure that this will
technically work
if yeah now we heard from representative
Aaron right about there may be some
bills here right
so but that's landfills that's landfills
right okay but it's not this fishing
game kind
of not end dangerous speeches find out
get I I'm not aware of any bills aside
from Senate Bill 110 and maybe maybe a
few others but nothing significant that
would address what sections uh two
through eight are trying to address okay
so the only possible problem it seems
like in
section uh is section for this
appropriation right otherwise yes the
the appropriation that's a duplicate
yeah and then obviously the red lines
would need to kind of go over what
what's in the existing version of hb2
but yes yes I agree I wish we didn't
have to spend as much time on these
changes when we're trying to balance the
budget yes I agree with you okay all
right why don't we keep going section
seven okay this this is on
page uh eight of house bill
to eight
yeah if people are following house buil
to section seven six s and8 uh implement
the D the dncr portions of this proposal
and so they're moving the environmental
reviewers from from dncr to Dees okay um
that that happens in house bill one and
House Bill two is the act the
authorities for what those reviewers do
Dees okay and so the oh so the only
change here is the 180 days correct
correct gotcha okay and
then um we haven't gotten there but
there
are some cleanup uh technical changes
that we need to make to what we provided
in the budget it's eliminating the
rivers Council which is a a a
non-governmental entity um in Statue
they Pro they are able to sort of
investigate Wetlands permits and provide
feedback to us actually before we get to
section 13 yep should we talk about
section
nine 9 10 and so on yes so sorry we're
kind of flipping between a bunch of
documents here so 910 and then it's 1516
so I I they're kind of out of order and
House Bill 2 but um going back to that
spreadsheet where the title is House
Bill 2 proposal
descriptions um that's overwater Boat
House guard rails so over overwater boat
houses we re historically have not
approved those um at the at the
department we've we've approved Doug in
boat houses and we
recently received a a legal
interpretation from the Attorney
General's office that the we can't look
at the Aesthetics we can't look at that
uh anything other than the environmental
factors when it comes to boat houses and
so they have sort of reverse that uh so
what we are going to be seeing in the
future are proposals for overwater boat
houses and we will not we would have to
consider them and potentially approve
them if they meet all the environmental
um criteria and so would would such a
boat house be floating or would it be
attached to a to a piling of some kind
or uh it would be attached to some sort
of dock or piling or something of that
nature um so it would have an access way
to to the shore but the pro the problem
that was foreseen here is that because
of that uh changeing
interpretation you could you could build
something pretty large and still receive
approval multiple stories and um other
issues with that yes and so what this is
attempting to to do is limit it to one
story and say that it needs to be
related to boat boats or boating
activity um there was some concern in
the governor's office when we let them
know about this technical or this legal
interpretation this change um and it is
a major change because these do go in
front of the governor and Council as
well because they are uh technically the
owners of the of the public water the
land under the public water and so um
they wanted to put some guard rails on
on boat houses and what what might be
proposed um otherwise you might end up
with very large structures coming in
front of the governor and Council I see
I um gave these sections to the
resources committee uh chair but I
haven't heard back yet so okay go ahead
but it sounds like much of this is being
driven by your Communications with the
attorney general uh it is a recent it's
a change in interpretation of the law
and so so we we are now required to
consider these and potentially approve
them regardless of the size we have to
only consider the environmental aspects
of the of the application and so you
could get something that's 10 stories
and we may be have to send it to
governor and Council gotcha where's the
is
n so nine nine and 10 sections 9 and 10
on page nine they create the definitions
uh what a boat house is and they also
create a definition of what the
structural height is and
then um you know in sections 15 and 16
which are on
page
12 those
Define struct uh those
those set out uh the structural height
18t it would have been nice if they were
grouped together but they were they're
so me oh I see stri yes I see line 11 of
page
12 no second floor all this sort
stuff but this is all new right I mean
this is a that that is that is a new
paragraph um we historically have not
approved overwater boat houses we have
approved Doug in boat houses um and
because of the change in legal
interpretation in overwater Bow house is
actually more environmentally friendly
than in Dugen bow house and therefore we
will be we we are required to consider
these overwater structures does a dugin
so so the question is if if these are
more environmentally friendly than the
dugin one why are we restricting them
why wouldn't we encourage them you know
so it has been a historic legal
interpretation that we could not approve
them and is is a recent in sort of our
the commissioner and in myself looking
into this issue we have determined with
the Attorney General's office that that
is no longer an accurate legal
interpretation um it it's been a
it goes back to the 1980s I don't know
if you want to add to
that no I and again so given that legal
interpretation we the presumption was
and obviously it' be up to a legislature
that others around the Lakes wouldn't
want to see two three four five story
developments happening over the over the
water blocking their views and things
like that yeah based on our experience
that would not go over well so so we the
thought was to put some guard rails
legal guard rails low and then maybe
change all right represent
evil represent doesn't matter I
win couple questions so with the dugin
boat houses they still have to go
through a wet Wetlands permit right
because they're in that Wetlands
range they they would have to get a
permit and oftentimes we we do if
they're if they're large structures
major major structures we do send them
to governor and Council as well um where
that sort of policy decision is made
whether or not to move them forward or
not we we simply look at the the criter
the environmental criteria on the
dugins um you know this this new legal
interpretation to expand the universe to
overwater that that could create I think
a I think we were seeing a potential
political problem right where you have
these giant five six story structures
being proposed and we would have to
approve them and move them on to the
governor and Council and so I think that
the intent of this was to uh set some
guard rails around that so that and it's
very black and white because you know
obviously that is the pview of the
legislature to set uh the Aesthetics you
know we're the environmental agency so
we we uh we should not be in the realm
of determining whether something is
aesthetically pleasing or or not and I
think that's that was uh the intent here
was to actually lay the Aesthetics piece
out in statute okay two more question
two more questions um so with the over
thewater boat houses so you're
restricting the height but what if a
there's an existing boat house and they
the owner wants to increase the square
footage um is that covered would that be
covered under your Authority so th so
this is only affecting things after I
believe it's February of
2025 okay so so if they want so if they
wanted to come in for a modification uh
they could if they're if they're kind of
replacing in kind if you will we would
we would allow that okay but what if
footage you
want you know maybe maybe the boat house
now is you know suitable for one boat
what if they wanted to increase the
square footage so they could fit you
know maybe kayaks or maybe a small
boat okay yes uh thank you for the
question um as you as you're aware with
with um docking structures there's a
limit to the size of the structure based
on the Frontage that the person owns and
and that has to do you know basically
the number of slips that they can have
on that Frontage so there is a limit to
what they could have in terms of the
size of one of these um structures based
on the Frontage that they own so we
would review it just like we' review any
other docking structure and I think one
of the things that that helps with this
proposal is it allows us to apply the
least environmentally impacting
principle to all docking
structures um B I think it's very hard
anyone to argue that a dugin boat house
is the least environmentally impacting
structure okay and so we would take the
approach of do you meet the you know
under our Wetland rules do you meet the
requirements for a permanent structure
on the on the shoreline if you do
really doesn't matter to us oh do you
meet and and the size of that structure
is governed by the Frontage that you own
after that it really doesn't matter to
us whether it's a permanent dock or a
boat house but I think there was concern
about that becoming a lighthouse or
something you know some very you know
you know building yeah and hence the
height restriction it's the most minimal
architectural restriction that we could
add okay I got you so it would really
fall under docking structure than the
boat house and then but over thewater
boat houses are they still still subject
to um any town uh building permit
requirements that that varies um but one
of the things that the reason for this
is that um because it's over submerged
public lands of State lands there's
certainly questions about the
applicability of town building codes and
and so the the need for some sort of
Statewide uh guard rail okay one more um
now so if you have over theater boat
houses but they're not subject to uh
Town Authority as far as building
permits could they still be added to the
assessed value of the onland structures
and
property this is getting outside of my
realm of understanding this would be
more of a municipal
question unfortunately I don't know the
answer to that okay thank you do do you
regulate docks and like how long the
dock can be and how heavy and things
like that yeah you know we regulate
docks and as I mentioned there's there's
uh restrictions regarding the size of
the docks and the number of slips based
on the amount of Frontage and um based
on the you know the depth of the water
so that's that's a big part of our
permitting program and so this will you
know by boat houses has been part of
that but it's had this not necessar
logical conclusion that you know a dug
in boat house is possible when it really
has a pretty large impact on the banks
of the of these water bodies presumably
a a boat house has a septic connection
right to to land right so uh wait these
would be not boat houses these would be
not struck dwellings over water this is
and also that's part of what the
guardrail here is to say this is only
for the servicing of boats oh okay house
for the boat not for the people yeah
right I see exactly uh we can't have a
bathroom is that what you're saying
correct it does not have a bathroom
dwelling over water is an entirely
different thing and those are would only
be you know I got it okay repres
jurisdictional would they still allow a
dugin boat house seems to me it even get
more complicated now you're really into
dredge and fill into the into the lake
or the river or whatever uh the answer
is no we would not that's what I thought
yeah and I think that that brings some
sort of logic to this process any that
are left 100 years old or 50 years old
yeah the pre-jury would remain obviously
they would not have to be removed all
right represent V just less of a
question more of a comment I would just
say that I I really appreciate and
applaud you including this in hb2
because living in an area with Lakes
these things everywhere are growing like
Topsy at every opportunity and I think
this is a good provision and thanks for
bringing forward thank you okay but I
still represented Lehman yeah thank you
Mr chairman notice we kind of jumped to
boat houses but we jumped over the fees
on 14 I know if you're going to talk
about those or I guess I had a question
for you and representative wer whether
we ship those proposals over to Ways and
or oh I see yeah yeah did you C copy
them on those pages or not NE
necessarily I don't
think okay let me make a note of this
14 okay and those and and just to
reiterate those are to support the
additional staff coming over after this
bium um the the intent there is to
ensure that we have enough resources to
make to to pay for those positions once
I was going to add I like that
approach okay good so um all
right so all right now we're done with
boats right
so Phil do you want to stay up here for
the the rivers Council um so we talked
about the fee increases that's 11 and 12
so we'll go to the next page um on the
chart we have section 13
which is uh we we named it streamling
permanently only in that it does a
couple of um specific things relative to
The Rivers Council and the extensions
for um for permits and I Phil you want
to kind of describe those in a little
bit more
detail surely uh so in the in the
Wetland statute uh local conservation
commissions are able to put what's
called a 40-day hold on a Wetlands
permit which um you know basically
prevents the department from making a
decision for 40 days and that gives
these count these what um conservation
commission's time to review the project
and give us comments I think what they
wanted the point of that part of the
statute is to prevent the department
from quickly approving something before
a a Conservation Commission that meets
monthly is able to meet and provide
comments um that statute went a little
bit further to say that a Conservation
Commission can request a second 40-day
hold
um in our experience that happens very
very very rarely um and just through you
know knowing the uh the objectives and
the priorities of the uh Governor we
were looking for ways that we could um
eliminate requirements that you know
aren't adding a lot of value and maybe
slowing down the process and so um we
suggested that as a as something that
could be removed um in reviewing that
section it it there's it also me
mentions uh local River advisory
committees which are duly appointed
committees that are around the
designated Rivers uh in the state and
they provide similar functions as a
Conservation Commission and they're
place-based they you know they're uh
they have eyes and ears on the ground
they can tell us if a proposal you know
has some flaws or something that we're
not aware of um the there was also in
the statute we realized the New
Hampshire Rivers Council which is is in
a a nonprofit organization that's not um
one of these con these local River
advisory committees it's Statewide it
doesn't have that same place-based
nature uh so it just didn't seem to fit
with what else was in the rest of the
statute so that was the suggestion okay
to eliminate that that being able to
hold the permit for for that Rivers
Council um we don't provide that to any
other sort of private nonprofit um
entity so we thought that was
appropriate and getting rid of the
40-day hole is what that does there is
one small going back to the redline
version sorry I'm going to to different
documents there we're adding we missed
one reference to The Rivers Council so
we're adding that in when we when we
prepared this change and so that's
that's um I see yeah so there's that and
then so if there's no questions on that
one I'll jump to 14 which is alteration
of permits basically we're striking that
section and we're adding the language of
s SP 110 that has had a a lot of debate
in the senate committee and has a lot of
good work was done on that and so we
feel like that proposal uh it's the
permit by notification and the increase
in a alteration of terrain fees those
two things kind of go hand inand in that
proposal and so the the hope is that
this committee would adopt the s sp110
language um to to to move that forward
so there's that so that's what is going
on there there's a lot of red but
basically it's it's eliminating that
section 14 and replacing it with
sp110 um representative evil yeah thank
you Sor just going up in the red you're
de trying to follow the bouncing balls
but uh that uh it it was old
C1 it says a project that would result
in a discharge of storm water within a
quarter of a mile of a Class A surface
water are you removing a approval
requirement for that or did it move to
some other home the no so that that was
in addition to when we when we were
creating this permit by notification
language we wanted to put those two
criteria C1 and C2 we realized that we
could just write that we would have
rulemaking ability and we can
incorporate that in the rules and and we
will incorporate that in the rules yes I
heard it
okay can you clear clarify for me when
you say permit by notification what does
that mean so a permit by notification is
when a developer or applicant submits uh
a proposal to us and the plans in that
proposal um instead of a a review uh
beforehand we would um have those plans
and we would review them after the fact
and make and then uh make sure that that
they're in compliance with all the
requirements after the fact Phil can
provide a little bit more detail around
that because again he lives the day
today but that's
yes yes so the the interest of this the
um enr committee from the Senate was to
speed up permitting and so they're
asking for these smaller projects which
were at the lower end of our alteration
of train category could we just you know
we have good Engineers they develop
plans um if they submit them and there
you know um then you don't have to
review them before the work could start
you know the work could start upon
notification of the work uh and then if
there were any deficiencies that we were
to discover either through review of the
plans or through a field inspection you
know obviously they'd have to fix them
so it it converts uh it goes a bit from
a permitting upfront to an auditing type
function uh and so we thought for these
smaller projects that would be
appropriate and it didn't it still gives
us authority to take enforcement should
we need to but it does allow for you
know 20% of our applications to move
forward at a much faster Pace but these
are still designs made by a licensed
person right correct it must be
submitted by a professional engineer and
stamped okay so this is an area where
I've heard that somebody complained to
me it was a builder that when they build
in
Maine they just go to the professional
license Ed person that person gives them
a a stamp plan and then they build to
that plan and that's it they don't have
to go to your the equivalent of Dees and
get their engineer to check the licensed
person's plan that it's still okay you
know what I mean so it's like in New
Hampshire there's like two such
Engineers involved in any plan sort of
thing whereas in Maine they say well the
person's license the what they're doing
and therefore it's okay is that all true
or is that am I sort of simplifying it
somehow or well I guess I'd characterize
it in terms of the measure twice cut
once adage um about well over well more
than half and close to all of our
reviews discover deficiencies in the
storm water um
calculations uh and you know these are
areas where I think we have very
talented Engineers on staff who are
stretching things and you improving the
process and um for an alteration of
terrain we're talking about 100,000
square ft which is almost is 2.3 Acres
these are Big projects and um the goal
here is to uh protect the the ab
buttering properties from changes in the
hydrology so you imagine a you know a
big box store that's going to go from
Woods to Pavement it's going to change
the way the storm water runs and we've
all help dealt with the the questions
from people and constituents who say you
know this development came in and now I
have flooding in my basement now I you
know it didn't always used to be this
way but now my driveways you know washed
out at the bottom the goal here with
alteration of terrain is that the post
construction conditions match what the
preconditions were but if it's a house
then there isn't such a heavy review is
correct because because a house is you
know 4,000 you know 5,000 square fet so
that's not even relative to this we only
looking for for housing we're generally
looking at subdivisions and subdivisions
with 20 to 30 Lots I understand repr
W one of the reasons why we always have
to look through hb2 and wonder why they
did what they did is one year it was
heavily filled with OP office of
Professional Licensing and
certification and they eliminated 30
licenses one of them being an engineer
and an architect and I said what's going
on here and they said well we don't get
many complaints about them we don't
think we need them and I said I guess
you don't know the law if you want to
submit a plan to the to the um
registered Deeds it better be from a
licensed engineer if you want to go to a
planning board it better be a licensed
engineer if you want to go to you it
better be from a licensed I'm thinking
who comes up with this stuff so every
time I look at hp2 I look at it with a
jaist eye from some of the past
experience that who the heck comes up
with this stuff that's why I ask who
initiates this and it's obviously
not your Division and not probably from
some Engineers because when I saw that
one from oplc I couldn't believe it
eliminating 30 licenses because we
haven't had
complaints about some of and the other
ones that got very upset were Landscape
Architects because there were only 200
of them so why do we need to bother okay
uh yes representative evil yeah I was I
was just going to say that um on the on
these permits that relate to alteration
of terrain and it at a time when the
storm uh intensity is increasing so we
have like 100e storms every other year
um I just know from being on a planning
board in my town for almost 20 years the
storm water issue and the wetlands
incursion and the number of people
complaining about water in their
basement when they didn't have it before
it's just really really important which
is another reason why we just have to be
sure that you have the funding to do the
job that you're setting yourselves up
for uh absolutely right representative
this is uh this this type of permit is
incredibly important to to ensuring
we're not you know properties are not
flooding out their neighbors or uh
anything like that and so you know we we
take that very seriously um you know we
we do believe the 100 to 100
50,000 it could be eligible for a permit
by notification process but anything
above that I think you know the original
proposal in sb10 just to give you a
quick note was 200,000 square feet and
we had said that's that's going a little
too far those are huge that's a huge
development so we we paired it back to
150,000 Square fet in that in this and
so that's that's our um that was our
desire here was to we think that's the
right the right uh thresholds
so if I wanted to know the fiscal impact
of this new section 14 I should go look
at the fiscal note on Senate Bill 110 is
that it or I so there was an amendment
to Senate Bill 110 I don't know if
they've submitted a fiscal note to us
recently for that Amendment but they
meliss and but but the this includes the
fee increases so it would cover the cost
of any reduction in review that that
would occur here so so it it would be a
net positive for the Department um under
this proposal or for the general fund
what year Senate Bill 110 2023 202 this
this year 20252 thank you a net positive
for the department or for the general f
for the
department so you can do your job to
well and and the idea behind that was it
would be in coordination with hb2 to
ensure that we had the resources to take
on on the additional staff so that's
part of this the additional staff from
the other two agencies that we just
mentioned I see okay Melissa you wanted
to say something I was just going to say
um our office just got the amendment to
this bill this morning so it's already
okay so in the you will have something
yeah okay representative evil didn't the
governor put another
$275,000 in your budget for this no it
was something else it's okay that so
that was for that supervisor position I
believe that was section four in hb2
and I think Melissa's going to work with
Susan Carlson to ensure that that's
that's synced up thank you
representative R I just want to confirm
are all the fees you collect for permits
do they go into the water resources fund
do any go to the general fund all of the
fees that we collect for land resources
management go into um the Water
Resources fund okay thank
you okay for trash is that coming next
so
the next thing is the solid waste site
evaluation committee um this is a very
large proposal it's about 10 pages long
um the the summary of this one is that
um let me just get my notes out here it
establishes a solid waste site
evaluation committee for large
facilities 100,000 uh tons of throughput
or more um excluding Municipal
facilities and and it includes expansion
so if an existing facility wanted to
expand and that expansion is more than
100,000 tons of throughput which is how
much waste is going through the facility
uh whether it's disposed there or it's a
transfer station they would need to come
in uh they would obviously do all the
dees and other permitting reviews at the
state level and then they would filter
to this new entity it's a it's the site
evaluation committee and it's a me it's
a five member board and they would look
at things
like um the types of waste and
quantities of waste and their
characteristics the sources of waste
where the waste is coming from as a
factor um visual impacts uh impacts the
property values tourism outdoor
recreation traffic noise and odor uh
economic impacts and any other
information requested by the committee
and
so the the intent of this was to have
this this new entity look at impact that
are not already contemplated by other
state agencies or Dees and so uh and to
allow for greater Regional and Municipal
input uh and and the folks who live in
those areas input into the process and
so um is this taken from some Bill or no
uh this is this is house bill this isn't
House Bill 2 no it's it's a own proposal
it is similarly situated as the existing
site evaluation committee but a lot of
the technical defects for that uh that
committee which which considers energy
facilities have been corrected in this
in this proposal some of the nuances new
stuff right yeah so there's it's new
stuff okay fine um and so when I read
this proposal my assumption was you will
never open a dump in New Hampshire again
that's the way it reads
I I don't think that's the intent I
think the intent is to have a greater I
mean 12 pages of this you can't do this
you got to go there you got to go here
you got to go everywhere you got to
check odor if anybody can see it from a
surrounding
town it's bad all this kind of stuff
it's just it's going to make it
impossible to ever open a dump again in
new yeah I I would tend to think you
could get representative evil or some
some friendly lend lator to put this in
as a bill and see what happens to it you
know me this was this was the governor's
proposal um it does include a one-year
moratorium or greater on on uh Solid
Waste
facilities um or until the rules have
been passed by the committee so it may
take 18 months for the committee to pass
rules through jail car or something like
that so it would be whatever one of
those whichever one is later and so this
was the governor obviously VI L the
governor's proposal it's something she's
very passionate about I'm sure you've
you've heard that um it's the intent is
not to and and I think we we helped
write it to ensure that it would not uh
stop all landfills in New Hampshire
right I think the idea is to allow for a
lot more public input and consider the
things that probably should be
considered but are not considered
currently under these un for these types
of proposals
um and oh God what's the effect on the
budget of these section so the inten is
for it to be self-funded similar to the
site evaluation committee when
applicants come in for a uh review they
would pay a filing fee under this uh
proposal it's
$20,000 and then additional to that uh
it's for every it's scales up so
something that's around 500,000 tons of
throughput would be around $660,000
the applicant would have to pay into
this into this proposal is there any is
there a similar fee now or not uh we do
have we do have Solid Waste um Fe
application fees at the department but
this would be a separate review it be
outside of the there this would be
administratively attached to us
similarly to how the Energy site
evaluation committee administrative
attached to the Department of energy but
it would be self-funded it would be it
would it would sort of be outside of our
on top of existing fees on top of
existing fees representative e will then
representative okay so just in the um
chair Wier referred to his conversation
with um chair Aaron that there is some
bills that have been working their ways
way through the house regarding
landfills so two of them haven't
actually passed yet but one did pass
yesterday this HB 215 and it actually is
something called the net benefits
analysis and the idea of the net
benefits analysis is very similar to the
kind of thing that you have here for the
for the SEC so I'm just saying in terms
of um a more Global approach to these
things that concept is in is embodied in
this so it's so it does align with house
policy at this point because we've U
adopted this bill so the other bill
that's out there that just came through
Ena is a three-year as opposed to a
one-year moratorium and then there's
another bill hb77 that I'm actually not
as familiar with but though I just
wanted to mention that those were the
three bills that um that chair Aaron had
mentioned um okay to so HB 215 what else
yeah and I I asked U Melissa to make
copies for us so that's here um that's
just different approach it's
not embodying the SEC approach right I'm
just talking about the more Global
whatever you want to say and I would
want to comment on that you know we we
would certainly prefer this proposal
obviously it's the governor's proposal
number one um and we're part of the
executive branch but number two you know
I think the difference between 215 uh HB
215 and this proposal is that this
independent a or body would make these
uh determinations where as we don't have
the the expertise to um consider I think
a lot of what's in in HB 2 25 and I
don't know Mike do you want to comment
on on the some of the Nuance differences
between those these two proposals sure I
well I think yeah two as as assistant
commissioner Kos indicated there's
there's really two fundamental
differences I think between the between
what's in hp2 and what's in 2115 first
um it uh it is it would be Dees that
would make the decisions in both it
still creates a bifurcated process so
there's a and and and the second
difference is is that it puts that
initial sighting decision that the site
evaluation committee would make that
idea in 215 happens first rather than
afterwards so that's a fundamental
difference and um so and again the other
piece is that it would have Dees making
these decisions not only in its normal
traditional permitting um uh program but
also these uh broader evaluations of
potential Community impacts like
property values uh business impacts um
Recreation and uh uh you know various
aesthetic issues so um we had testified
on 215 when it was in house Ena and uh
you know the we didn't take a position
on the bill the issues we identified as
potential concerns were that we didn't
feel that our staff you know we have
very good scientists in Engineers who
are absolutely prepared to do the work
we do which is to evaluate uh the design
and operation and construction of a
proposed facility um and to make sure
that that the permit if it's issued
provides all the the necessary
protections for Environmental
Protections but we're not experts on um
property values or uh business
recreational impacts scope is a little
too right so so I think that you know
and certainly we we support what's in
hb2 I I think what we see as an
advantage there is that that's a broader
group of folks who are brought together
who under the provisions of the bill can
bring in experts as they need to to
evaluate these V and even require the
applicant to to provide reports or
studies of various issues so I think
that's an important issue the other
piece I think is that um
in the uh the build in hb2 the the after
the fact after so the way it's
structured any Dees per permits whether
they be a solid waste permit or an air
permit or aot or or a Wetlands permit
would need to be evaluated in a decision
made before it would come to that second
step if any of those were denials then
probably the project would be dead at
that point there would be no need to go
to that second step but if those were
all approved then it could go to the
site evaluation committee and the
advantage there is that then when you're
making these key broad decisions about
broader Community impacts you know
exactly what the project looks like it's
been through the vetting and a
permitting process at the department you
know and and anybody who's gone through
that process knows that from the time of
the initial application to a final
decision by the department project
changes a bit you know we say it's not
complete and they change their proposal
a little bit they may make design
changes based on our technical review so
under the the program the the process
that's described in
hb2 you're going to know exactly what
that project is at that point and the
project that comes to the site
evaluation committee will be very well
defined and that will put that Committee
in a great position to actually make
these evaluations on these broader
impacts does the site evaluation
committee have any full-time
employees so that's one one of the
technical changes we need to make uh the
original draft and it got lost in the
drafting process I don't know where but
it got lost in the drafting process we
are uh originally is proposed it was
supposed to be the administ current
administrator of the site evaluation
Committee in the uh in the Pu uh that
person has some bandwidth as I
understand it to be able to perform
these tasks when needed and so the idea
was for that person they're really a
process type person they they uh accept
the applications they do all the filing
they work work on that and make sure
that the committee is updated and
prepared when they are uh deliberating
in public and so that is uh what we
would uh need for a technical change to
ensure that the administrator of the
current energy sec would also be able to
do this uh again it's a process person
it's not a policy role it's really a
process role and and and they're really
uh trained in that so okay
representative Ms thank you Mr chair um
there was quite a bit of work done last
bi Anum and maybe even before that to um
streamline the operation of the uh the
site evaluation committee for energy
projects uh was that uh were those
changes uh kind of Incorporated in this
as well so they taking advantage of that
work yes so one one of the biggest
pieces of that was streamlining the
membership there were quite a few
members of the SEC and for for for some
dockets that are ongoing there still are
for uh new dockets after that change was
made it's only a five member and that's
Incorporated in here um so it' be a five
member board panel and uh some of the
other efficiencies were also also
adopted in here as well um around public
process and all of that um you know the
the hope is that this would provide a
lot of community uh in public process to
ensure that those communities have a
have a say in in what's what's what's
being proposed from it from the
standpoint that the state agencies don't
are currently
regulate representative thank you um so
I'm I'm going to admit that this was of
great interest to me and so I did spend
some time with the folks at Dees and we
had a really I thought fruitful and long
conversation about it I really like the
idea of having a separate site
evaluation committee for landfills um I
think they put a lot of pro thought into
the process here and comparing it with
what they do um in the energy context I
mean I just know from my own experience
working with them the establishment of a
new major landfill in the state of New
Hampshire as you know has just been an
unbelievably contentious difficult
longstanding uh
process I don't know if you would say it
I feel like it it eats the the staff
time alive over there it's a really
difficult process and uh and I
understand why because there's a lot of
concern and this sort of thing would
sort of remove it from Dees make it a
freestanding um process and you know
really the SEC would for this wouldn't
really be active unless there's a major
solid waste facility application coming
through right so it's the same with the
p the SEC for energy that's why I think
the administrator has some bandwidth
right because they're not always um
active I just to share with the
committee I had a few concerns one was
to um right now Dees permits are
appealed to the waste management Council
and I was concerned when I saw that the
waste management Council um chair was
also the chair of the SEC and they said
that the way this is set up and I see it
here the the appeal process is through
the superior court so I thought that was
really um really a good thing um I think
it's worth looking at this hb25 just to
combine just to compare the metrics a
little bit um so that maybe there's some
alignment I do know that uh we have a
the the ENA is going to be proposing a
three-year moratorium we'll have to see
how all that works out um one of the
things I was concerned about was the
$20,000 fee and you just said something
Adam and I and I might have missed it I
I felt like there maybe should be
starting at 20,000 and maybe graduated
up because you know if you're proposing
a
500,000 ton whatever a day or whatever
it is um uh transfer or landfill seems
like you could pay a little more for all
the incredible amounts of work that's
going to go into this versus a smaller
facility so if if you let me I can
comment on that so uh the base charge is
20 ,000 for 100,000 uh tons of
throughput and then it does escalates
$1,000 per additional 10,000 tons of
throughput so uh I used 500,000 tons as
an example but that would yield uh
$6,000 in revenue from the filing fees
and just for context uh some of the
members do get paid for their time uh
because you know it's very difficult to
find people for these volunteer roles
it'd be around $50 a days is what we
calculated it out um so even if they
went you know uh you know 50 days you
know they would only be uh it would be
only like
$25,000 and so the fee we we do feel
like the fees would cover the way it's
written right now we do feel like the
fees would cover that um the cost of of
of this um as it's
written Ju Just um even in the context
of a Cella type proposal you think
enough
really it would really depend upon how
long that process went on right I mean
the we you know we have a have had an
application before us on a controversial
project two different applications for
six years now and there's been
tremendous interest in that so it has
had a great a very significant impact on
staff time and our resources in the
agency I'm not sure that the solid waste
sighting evaluation committee as is
envisioned in hb2 would encounter the
same impacts on time that the department
has so well one of the benefits and and
I know we're getting short on time I
guess but uh you know one of the
benefits of having it at the end of the
process rather than at the beginning is
that these proposals are vetted we kind
of know where things are at the
Departments and and state agencies have
reviewed them so it is at by that point
if it does get approved it's a
relatively solid proposal for this group
to look at one of the reasons why some
of those things have been in front of us
for for some time is because of
incomplete applications and so um the
the the thought behind this was
hopefully they would have a more
complete applica or a a proposal would
have a more complete application by the
time the state agencies are done with
that process and then it would go to
this new entity represent Ms thank you U
would this committee have um oversight
for um Solid Waste incinerator or refu
energy
facility yes this would be any facility
whether it's a landfill an incinerator
or even a transfer facility that has a
annual throughput of greater than
follow up and it is that specified in
the definitions I mean is it clear that
that's what that that includes that it's
a great question the definition is clear
the um I I would note that um the the
term that's being defined is a major
solid waste disposal facility and it
might be that it would be appropriate to
take the word disposal out of there and
just say major solid waste facility
because when you read the definition it
includes facilities that had collect
store treat transfer or dispose of waste
so the the the definition is correct the
name of the term maybe could use a
little take the disposal
out representative
lean thanks Mr chairman maybe
representative evil can help me because
I'm drawing a blank on the facility that
was such a controversial sighting up
north next to the lake yeah right Dalton
that's the cassella proposal
correct so I know that facility get that
whole thing is on hold are they subject
to these fees that you're proposing here
or is there separate fees that are
charged to people that are out there now
trying to get a site approved uh so they
so should this pass they you know if if
it has not gone through our process
which they do have a pending application
in front of us it's I want to be clear
it's not on hold it you know if this
does include a moratorium which would
put such facilities on hold until the
new committee adopts rules but they
would be subject to this should this
pass
before uh anything is approved at this
at the state agency level if that makes
sense yeah I follow thanks thanks Mr
chairman yes commissioner and quickly on
the adequacy of the the the the fees I
will remind the committee that the site
evaluation committee for energy covers
everything under the sun for an app for
facility this just covers the things
that my agency and other agencies aren't
covering so that so so the the workload
if you will though may be controversial
is much more is much smaller piece of
the pie if you will so that's the other
reason why we feel these fees are
adequate if that makes
sense all right uh very good so do we
have House Bill 215 I had her I had
Melissa C assigned assigned to to this
no it's not a is it a it just passed
yesterday on
the it was on the consent calendar
yesterday and it um has it come to
finance is my question is it assigned to
consent it it's referred to finance
yesterday it was refer anyway all right
so good and and you mentioned two other
bills that are related what are those so
I I mean Adam if you want to I don't
know the N what is it one HB 171 I think
is the one on the moratorium and that
came that that's correct HB 171 is
representative German's Bill
establishing a uh well I think it
originally came in as a 5-year
moratorium and the committee has uh I
looked I think looked to amend it to the
three-year moratorium will beond next we
so it's still in process yeah or cor
whatever it's on the calendar for next
week next week it'll be exact I think
and there's also a Senate bill and then
yes the or well the uh yeah there is a
Senate bill um and I its number escapes
me at the moment Senator rosf for's Bill
which also establishes a moratorium and
then uh I believe the other bill that
representative eil was referring to was
hb77 that's representative Penza bill in
in housea and that that is actually
related to uh landfill setbacks and such
you know from very setbacks to surface
water water and other features so um I I
don't and that I think is going to be
exact next week as well yeah I don't
understand Melissa does that have an
FN
707 well no okay it can't be an early
bill because yeah they're all done on it
that's right that's right following the
bouncing balls okay all right very good
so I guess we'll have to think about um
this sort of stuff and I I try I'll try
to
yet we'll hear back from um
representative Aaron right
um yeah she could I did speak with her
and she was sorry she couldn't make it
today okay all right good all right is
there another second so so there are
some technical changes we're proposing
in the red lines to this uh we're we're
consolidating originally it's proposed
it's said they would have to hold a
public Hearing in every affected
municipality which is any where any
truck traffic would go we felt that we
could make that you know you know one
public Hearing in that area because it's
they're going to be close enough to all
go to that and then the committee will
have discretion to order additional
public hearings as necessary we just
didn't feel like uh you know proposals
coming through here needed to have TW
you know 20 different public hearings
for one proposal when they're all
relatively close together these towns so
um so there's that and then just some
technical changes around um you know
that the moratorium would be for any new
capacity the way it's worded now would
be any land landfill CH any change in
ownership or anything like that I
believe and so and Mike can speak to
that a little bit more but this would
just clarify that it's for any any new
capacity whether it's an expansion or or
new landfill or new waste
facility yes that's right the uh the
current language was discovered by one
of our Engineers who are good at those
things they they read the rules and they
see what they mean um the way it's
worded right now we we administer our
whole Solid Waste regulatory program
through a system of permits so even
after you get an approval to expand your
per your landfill for example you may
have three or four other permit
modifications you'll have to come in for
for final design approval uh change your
operating plan and such and the way it
was worded it made it sound like all of
those approvals would be held up for a
year um under the uh suspension which
was clearly not the intent I think of
the of the of the language so we just
clarified it to show that it's really
the the issues that would come before
the site evaluation committee would only
be uh uh applications that sought to
provide uh expanded capacity or new
capacity or continued capacity for an
existing
facility okay yes representative R yeah
I just want to confirm something um
regarding on your Redline document um
uh regarding those public hearings and
the public information center even
though they're going to be um for the
municipality where the site is
proposed other community members from
neighboring communities would still be
invited to participate that's correct
yeah and in paragraph two again I I
apologize for not having the sections
connect to hb2 on this but um in
paragraph 2 it does say the committee
May order the applicant to provide such
additional public sessions in affected
municipalities as are reasonable to
inform the public of the proposed
project and so even if all the community
members or groups that that they
couldn't make it that to that one public
hearing that they have the this
committee could order additional ones if
they felt that more needed to be done
there and so I we we felt that have
leaving it to the jurisdiction or uh
yeah jurisdiction of the committee was
the was the right way to go on this
instead of requiring you know 15 to 20
public individual public hearings if
that makes makes sense yeah I I agree
with that my um concern is just to
ensure that people that may be in other
affected municipalities are aware of
that public hearing they could travel to
the Imp you know to the municipality
where the sit's located similar Mr whims
at the way we've done the Pas hearings
and Communications I me may be held in
marac but other community members are
welcome to attend and provide cont
comment and ask questions I think we had
one in Lichfield absolutely you know
anytime we have a public information
meeting or a public hearing it's it's
broadly advertised and we welcome
anybody who wants to come and attend and
there's language in hp2 that provides
that effective municipalities absolutely
have a seat at the table to provide
their input not just citizens in those
municipalities but actually the local
government body as well all right thank
you okay all right shall we move ahead
to
um I think page 65 is it yes page 65 and
so you'll it corresponds to the Chart uh
section
156 that is a section to repeal in in
the 2023 budget we had two uh an
appropriation in FY 26 and an
appropriation FY 27 for the state aid
grant program it's a total of $30
million this is uh getting rid of those
sections um and so that that saves $30
million for for the committee yeah you
prefunding Su Susan Carlson will be able
to speak to this a little bit more uh
but I believe the reason for that is
because this was an HB to appropriation
and so it didn't let me yeah yeah um
essentially this is these are
Appropriations that have not yet
happened okay so this um in hp2 from the
last session they they essentially
appropriated $15 million in 26 and $15
million in 27 so um the slide I gave you
um when we met last week was about what
we currently have as Appropriations this
bium not what we are getting in the
future
oh okay so I thought this this money was
on that slide no no it was not okay so
essent go ahead so essentially what is
happening is that the the uh sag as you
call it is being defunded
from well the appropriation was made for
this by enum and now it's being that
appropriation is being repealed and so
the 30 million I is going back to the
general fund is that correct under hp2
laws of 23 they have set up an
appropriation for the 26 27 BM and so
yes we're taking that we're asking that
that be taken so you're losing that
money
yes yes but I want to be clear it's not
defunding the whole program it's just it
is it's just defunding the future
Appropriations that were put in
hb2 as a result of I think there was a
larger Surplus last session than right
obviously there's not one in this
session so that's I think that's the
goal of that was to help balance and so
we we of course have a Buco Buck bill
for $15 million per well 30 million so
so anyway I get it yeah so we'll have to
talk about it yeah I will anyway so
you're saying that sheet of paper you
gave us last time with all that leftover
money that's still there yes yes okay
represent them
mons you're good okay so to me this
particular section I I find it very
disappointing because I think it should
apply to how fiscal year
25 and not fiscal year 26 and 27 this is
leftover unspent
money right
and we have a serious deficit in fiscal
year 25 and to say take from the rainy
day fund and let me spend this in 26 27
is inappropriate okay would you agree
yeah okay some I see some noding heads
anyways but huh spend it in 26 27 well
it's it's not going to be available for
wastewater treatment projects by taking
the money isn't that the point no no no
but but because this is in houseu to
right and and if you read uh Melissa's
note here it says $115 million increase
in general fund in fiscal year 26 and 27
so if you look at our um if you look at
our um Surplus statement right it's in
26 and 27 1515 yes yeah yeah true so
that's correct because in 2023 it was
appropriated to 26 and 27 so by
repealing it it falls into 26 and 27
right but I think it should be a 30 and
meany yeah over right so this is
effectively let's take money out of the
rainy day fund and spend it in 26 27
that's the way I look at it um so I
would like assuming we want to do it
which I I I guess we want to I mean it's
a you don't want to but no I don't know
but it's a big dollar amount that it is
a big dollar amount but it is a it's a
program to help with wastewater
treatment plant I mean you you guys can
say what it's for better than I can yeah
yeah we know what it's
for but this total fund is hundreds of
millions right I mean the amount in
these kind of projects yeah well we
don't have a fund well
there's yes the project there's people
paying back and it's going back and
being loan out and yeah I mean the total
value right now in the Wastewater um sag
program we're paying out on 174 projects
the revolving
f it is not the revolving fund this is
strictly a general fund
appropriation okay this pays again real
quickly I know know the chair
understands he said but uh this is an
after to the fact after the project is
completed and commissioned this helps
pay debt
service okay yeah anyways but but it's
not yet been promised
anyway right that's corrected has not
yet been promised okay all right so all
right I guess do we're not necessarily
in agreement so let's let's wait on
doing something with this line okay all
right let's go to uh
um section 158 on page
64 one 157 is just a small technical
change it I think we already decided
that one oh have you we're we're already
good with
157 okay that's what my note
says so we we're getting F two extra
decimal
places
um 158 uh this language repeals a fee on
wastewater treatment system operators
uh the bureau that administrates uh the
administers the fee does not receive any
proceeds from the fees uh the fee
calculation is very arduous and often
not calculated correctly by the folks
who submit it so it's more of a burden
than it is a benefit for the program and
so that's why we're proposing to to to
get rid of it is there is there a
general fund impact no
okay all right shall we anybody want to
should we approve this
make sense make a motion to approve I'll
second it
okay all right all those in favor
accepting section
158 okay very good
then section 159 so 159 this language
repeals the out ofate Boer decal program
it was passed in 201 uh 19 and requires
a detail uh decal for the operation of
any out ofate watercraft the purpose was
to address uh the spread of invas of
aquatic uh species and organisms
unfortunately we found through this
process that the fee do not is not
Revenue positive it's costing us more to
administer the program than we actually
bring in um so far the state spent
$75,000 on it and we've received a
little over 40,000 and so that's why
we're requesting for this one to be
repealed as well um I think our concern
is especially with these tight tight
times that we're going into we want to
make sure that we're getting the best
use of our our resources as possible and
and we don't want to be administering
things that don't that are not Revenue
positive okay representative evil yeah
just we have a letter here that I asked
Melissa to share with everyone it's from
the New Hampshire Lakes folks and um
they're they're opposing the repeal you
we should give you a cop yeah I haven't
seen a cop yet but I I have one here
guess so maybe we could talk about it a
little more they they do admit here that
it hasn't been Revenue positive yet but
they were feeling like it would
be yeah that's
what you have the letter Mr CH everybody
here right out of state voter decal
y right you have the letter now I do
yes so I maybe we'd like an opportunity
I don't know what your thoughts are
maybe an opportunity to review this and
see where how they got to their
calculations but um our like I said our
feeling is that this has not been
Revenue positive um and I think our Our
concern is that it continue it will
continue to not be Revenue positive can
I ask you if it's doing anything about
invasive
species they don't have the money yet so
not now because it's costing us more so
we don't have any money to apply to that
it's costing us more to actually bring
in the fees but but
oh but the fact that you get the decal
doesn't mean your boat's been inspected
and therefore it doesn't have any
invasive species sticking to it or
something like that is that
no no no it's it's it's a purely
administrative process you a decal right
I see okay representative
minds but I I guess I would ask the
question but is is the threat of
invasive species something we should be
concerned about
a absolutely yes it is something to be
concerned about I think unfortunately
this specific fee we're not saying that
it's not um I think the specific fee
what we're saying here is that this fee
is not Revenue positive it's costing the
state money to administer it and that's
why we're proposing for it to be
repealed I know um I know it's not an
invasive species but I know
representative Rong has a separate bill
on license plates and and U CYO bacteria
and other things like that so I guess
I'm confused so are we are we are we
repealing the program
or the dcap decal just the decal and the
fee so the program still we're still
going to be yes checking for invasive
okay under under under under the law New
Hampshire voters pay a boting
registration fee we currently get $99.50
from that Boer registration fee this is
a decal a voluntary decal for out ofate
voters um to put a decal on their boats
um for this program what we have found
because this is um and we've had it run
by a third party because it's an all
online Pro program this one decal is not
making us any
money we are not eliminating program
we're not eliminating the instate fee
it's just this small decal program that
we're trying to eliminate that's costing
us money so are out ofate voters going
to have to pay
anything if we repeal
this it sounded like they don't have to
nowt volunt they don't have to but if
it's a problem why wouldn't we require
out of state voters to pay something you
don't have to give them a decal but just
make them well we can't force them to if
they're registered in their home state
we can't force them to re-register their
boat in our state
right right represent if you want rainy
peler is here he can answer more
questions I I uh I think um Adam had a
good suggestion maybe you could take
this back and and look at it I think New
Hampshire Lakes was very um concerned
that this potential Revenue stream for
them you know for this issue would be
cut
off R they just look at it thank you Mr
chair yeah especially with the cost of
the program I understand is that we're
paying that third party
$225,000 because the department couldn't
process credit card payments for this
decal where now the department does have
that capability and so the the cost of
running it would go down um so I mean
that's one thing clarifying and also I'd
be curious to why it made a you know if
you could clarify or confirm why it made
a profit in 2024 and not the other years
so yeah we'll wait to you for you to
come back but those would be my
questions but they have to print and
mail out a thousand decals right I mean
that's the correct okay representative
wer well we could just as easily have
invasive species coming in on the Ducks
and the
geese there's not much we can do about
that put a decal on them all right
representative C representative C thank
you Mr chair uh correct me if I'm wrong
but uh to alleviate representative ms's
concern
the uh Lakes Association has many
programs with local um uh water Lake
Associations and and uh volunteer groups
that monitor the uh invasive species
program and they do quite a good job as
as I know yes and and we we give them a
very healthy Grant in order to do that
to assist them with that program so this
will actually give us a little more
money to be able to give more grants out
okay but follow up the um So currently
the and I'm aware of the grants that are
given uh that is currently done through
the probably the $750 fee that we get
from our own and if this is a losing
program right now we're just taking
money away from that fund is that not
correct that's correct yeah and again
just to be clear the department is not
suggesting invasive species control is
something we want to get away from as
you allude to representative we'd rather
any monies go to addressing that rather
than to go to a vendor or go to a
sticker correct so thank you okay next
one is
uh um section 160 line 17 repealing the
drinking so with the UN uncertainty of
federal funding and several other issues
we we're actually asking this was
something we proposed to the governor's
office they were kind enough to put it
into the to
hb2 um but we are asking for this
language to be deleted um it's not
something that we feel is is prudent to
do at this time uh again with the
uncertainty of some of the federal
funding uh going forward we want to make
sure we have the revenue to be able to
um to pay for pay for staff in those
programs that that do such great work on
safe safe drinking water so okay
representative
I mean I guess I would at least like to
look at the statute before I yeah okay
so we'll we'll wait and go read the
section Mr chairman before we go too far
beyond
159 it does appear that if we can return
another
$25,000 to the invasive species account
versus paying for a decal we could check
this off by supporting the repeal So you
you're willing to vote for it I am no I
will second that motion
I just I feel bad because New Hampshire
Lakes had a different they've agreed to
just look at it and they're very
concerned about it Mr chair yeah I I'm
not ready to vote on it
because like the commissioner said we
should find out where they got these
numbers because as of last year they
were making money so if they're netting
$4,000 that we wouldn't have otherwise
that could go to that
program that's something we should
report is m l Moro here no no she sent
the letter and um asked for it to be
distributed because she unfortunately
couldn't be here this afternoon I mean
it probably wouldn't take very long for
you guys to just check it out we we can
check in with her and and get back to
the committee by email if that's if
that's all right okay thank you very
much okay we'll wait we'll wait all
right
now um let's go back to
can you describe what's in section RSA
8 so that is that's the repeal of the um
it's not the Safe Drinking Water Act in
its entirety don't get me wrong it's
concern it is a it's a permit fee to
operate uh for operators of drink water
systems and we were seeking to to get
rid of this fee because it is arduous to
to administer similar to the Wastewater
one but our it is revenue positive and I
guess and we do have a position on it
and with the uh again with the
uncertainty of federal funding and where
that stands uh at the federal level we
want to make sure we we are still
collecting Revenue to be able to pay for
those positions that do such good work
on on public drinking water systems and
so um before we were we were not as
concerned about that now with the the
some of the federal stuff going on we
want to make sure that we have that that
um it brings in approximately
$128,000 which is enough to cover the
cost of the position there's a position
yes there's a single position in
there and what do that the person just
collects the fees basically um yes they
collect the fees and and they do a lot
of other work yeah they do a lot they do
a lot of they work on the permits they
work on a variety of issues right
they're very they they work with the
drinking water systems on on various
issues that they're having with any
contamination uh other other issues as
well so they they they have a variety of
hats if you will um they they they're
very versatile uh but they are certainly
on this this this fee account um and our
our initial thought was to switch them
over to a federal account but given the
uncertainty we we want to delete this
language and retract retract it
yes representative R thank you Mr chair
um does this person also work with the
lead drinking the municipal water or
there's a program where I think Dees
reports every year or every other year
about the uh lead that lead testing of
um public and private schools and Child
Care Centers and I it's been a very
important program it actually identified
some very very serious lead problems we
had in one of our elementary schools is
this person involved in that program
this person works with a variety of
programs in the drinking water Bureau um
that being one of them I mean that's a
that's a joint effort between DHHS and
and uh Dees but uh so so she does wear
many hats and and and does interact with
that program as well as many others um
so so if if um
we maintain the repeal of that that's in
hb2 would that detri detrimentally
affect that lead monitoring
program we would have to move that pos
position onto federal funds as I
understand it and that that could uh
depending on what happens at the federal
level could have an effect on on that
program again it's very uncertain what's
happening at that at that level right
now there's there's uh various
legal actions and and things of that
nature happening and so we just want to
be safe on this one and and should we
not need this next session or even later
on in this session if we feel
comfortable moving forward we we would
potentially come back and and maybe
propose it but I think at this time
we're we're just hoping to retract the
you that's you maybe and not the
governor or we don't know uh we have not
on this specific one we have not but
this is something that we we put forward
to them as a proposal I got and uh you
changed your mind yes we have changed
our mind okay fine all right let's go to
161 so this one is uh it gives us the
ability to work on uh Dam easements and
get easements for various uh for the
horn horn pond dam and the um another
Dam in Conway to ensure that we have uh
enough area to put our materials uh work
with the Property Owners to get those
easements and so we do have one on the
one change on the red line to add
another Dam and new I switch to this
list and and really the idea is to do an
easement for a dollar and that would
allow us to put our um our materials and
and and and basically work work near
that site um and have enough area there
to be able to perform the work that's
needed I see so any problems with this
no okay yeah so why don't we approve it
with the redline version where does the
money come from work
on uh so cap capital budget yeah capital
budget okay all right so representative
Ms moves and representative rung seconds
that we approved the redline version of
section
161 any any further discussion no all in
favor
yeah are we going the have favor okay
good so that yes ref um I'm prepared to
accept the red line on the elimination
of the drinking water operator permit
fee to instead of repealing that to to
keep that um in you know to to take that
repeal line out of
hb2 so that we're accepting de's
recommendation I want to look at into
that one a little more okay yeah all
right let's go to so this one we
accepted
okay all right
162 162 is proposing to change the uh
qualifications of the waste management
division director uh right now it
requires a master's degree we're we're
uh proposing to bring it in line with
the rest of our division directors to be
a bachelor's degree um and that's and
that's something that is is supported by
the current Waste Management director
are we okay with this yes I would uh
make a motion to accept uh 162 all right
so moved in second U by representative
evil and representative rung to accept
Section 162 while in
favor yes all right one
opposed one
slow are you in favor he in favor okay
good you mentally okay good all right so
we accepted that one 163 air
resources so next page yes so this one
uh it it really is a a larger proposal
from 163 to uh 166 those those sections
um it eliminates the specific mentions
of uh membership organizations and
associations and leaves it to the
governor's office to choose uh it it
still retains the requirements you know
if you're a public health expert or a
Conservation Commission member but it
gets rid of the associations having to
nominate those positions and the reason
for that is because we've uh we we
haven't really found but the governor's
office in the past at least the past
governor's office I don't know if the
new one has experienced it or not the
past governor's office has uh had issues
with getting those associations to put
nominees up for them to potentially
accept and the number required so yeah
so 163 164 165 and 166 these are all
changing characteristics of commissions
and so on right so I I guess what I have
experienced and what I have heard
through the governor's office is that
frequently it's a nightmare to find
people to fill these positions and it's
a lot easier if a if an organization
marches in the door and say he says here
here's your name but so I didn't know
who generated the thought for this so
the the this came from not being able to
get some of these associations to put
forward a name some of them are very
diligent some of them are not um and so
that the thought was to do across the
board you know eliminate the requirement
then a specific Association put the put
forward these names that's not to say
that the governor's office or whoever in
the governor's office is is searching
for nominees for these would not work
with those associations I think that's
probably where they'd go to First and
having been in the governor's office in
the past that's often what we did for
things that didn't have a specific
Association attached to it but so but to
your point representative sometimes it
is a hindrance and sometimes it is a
benefit um but in and I think you you
have some experience and have heard that
some of these specifically to the
environmental councils have not been put
up nominations have not been put up and
some some of the reasons for that have
been the associations have not been
diligent but providing uh specific
members uh or or individuals up for for
nomination to the governor's office and
so that was the intent of this well I
mean I think actually we have the same
concern in and that is just trying to
promptly fill these positions because
it's just been incredibly difficult and
then just when I was Deputy speaker I
would be elated if I came across
something that I had to a point where
the where an association had to name the
person because I didn't have to go and
find somebody but I mean you can try it
and see if it works okay and and to be
clear we we try to have a pretty solid
wall between us and the environmental
councils because they are our appeals
venues and so we do our very best and
are very diligent about keeping a a
firewall between us and them and so um
you know we we we don't want to be in
the position of being the ones to
recommend people for these positions
frankly and and it has come down to that
in some instances so I just I I think
one of the ideas here was to ensure that
there was a an O more more available
candidates and more availability for the
governor's office to do their due
diligence on some on some of this
instead of having to rely on a specific
organization to make a recommendation
and as you'll see in some of these often
times it's multiple organizations and
they have to put up multiple nominees
and that becomes a an intense
proposition I'll put put it that way all
right represent Ms um I I have a I have
a little bit of a problem um
listing um as required Representatives
uh representatives from the uh the oil
industry and the natural gas
industry um without mentioning you know
the renewable energy industry I mean I
would like to see something that says
you know one member from the renewable
energy
industry since the renewable we talking
about this is on
163 since you know one of the benefits
of renewable energy is that it does um
so those are the existing members of the
council um that would be a policy
position for this committee to make I I
don't know that we we have a position to
take on that um we were specifically for
the public health uh position you'll see
that there's a strike through there and
just it says just in the field of Public
Health it's been many years since we
filled that specific position we haven't
been able to find anyone with these
qualifications and neither as the
governor's office and so we we felt that
it was important that we find someone to
sit on this Council and so that's that's
uh the governor's office find someone to
sell in this Council rather and that
that requirement be paired back a little
bit so that it's not as difficult to
find
a a unicorn if you will representative R
thank you Mr chair and um I apologize
that um I'm I'm looking back for more
basic information but I understand what
you're saying that these councils are an
appeals provide appeals venue for um
permitting correct what other value if
any do they provide to Dees so we do
I'll let the commissioner speak to this
but we do uh run our rules by these
councils so we go there and we provide
our Draft rules to them and they provide
input these are the industry experts in
uh these specific Fields so there's the
waste Council Waste Management Council
which is so you know solid waste
hazardous waste those types of things
there's the air Resources Council which
is experts in as you'll see here uh
different industries that have to do
with air permitting and air uh things
that have to affect air emissions
there's the wetlands Council which is uh
you know our Wetlands experts and then
there's the water Council which deals
with uh anything that's not wetlands in
the within the Water Division and so
these are really the industry I I say
all that these are the industry experts
they do provide good advice to us in in
our sounding board when we do do rule
Mak um so they do provide a benefit um
but you know I I I guess that's what I'd
say about it and I'll let yeah okay
thank
you chair could I just make a comment so
in
hb2 for the previous bium the uh go
Governor sonunu at the time recommended
that these councils become simply
advisory as I recall and um what
happened during the during the uh
process they retained The Advisory part
uh for questions of fact right they were
determined for questions of fact but
they have somebody from the AG for
questions of law I think they bifurcated
it that's how it ended up and then there
was just a study committee that just
completed a look at these environmental
councils and they decided to just leave
them alone but your question is good I
think it's a it's a different kind of an
app pellet format than a lot of agencies
yeah yeah one other I'm sorry so um with
the with their appeals responsibility if
does that still allow the um the the the
permit te to go to let's say Superior
Court if they disagree with the decision
of the council so goes to the Supreme
Court after the after the council so it
goes it's a direct route to the Supreme
Court okay thank
you so I I guess I'm okay with um moving
one of
the uh public interest one of the
general public numbers to a to a
renewable uh generating industry type if
you
want I mean the other thing you could do
I was thinking we have Reggie and all
these things right so well you could
combine the representative for oil and
natural gas into one person and then
just replace one of them with renewable
yeah but those are very different kinds
of things they're not they're not really
the same I will remind the committee
these are existing positions people in
these
positions um so I just providing that
yeah yeah and if I could also again we
don't have an objection per se but
you'll see the change here in line four
on six page 66 so the current language
says it has to be a steam power electric
generating uh that's being made more
generic so it's electric generating I
would presume in the context you're
talking about a renewable would be would
qualify too so there's a potential that
that could just be all encompassing so
but what were you saying Mr chair so I
said obviously they can't find anybody
who does steam right because no who
uses that actually was historically the
old PSNH plants and and now the
successors successor owners yeah but
there's there's I mean conquer got rid
of conquer Steam and all right actually
it's we're talking about uh marac
station or Schiller station are the two
that that qualify so so it's on the way
out so anyways no I was
saying it wouldn't bother me if we
there's there's six people here who are
general public or something
right so yeah so take make it five and
you know that's great how about that
yeah okay okay
so
um so represent Ms and and Melissa can
work out the actual language and we'll
righta wer I'll I'll make sure I say one
tree
hugging representative of the renewable
energy yeah I mean this is going to be
one person out of 12 or
[Laughter]
something all right let's move on to 164
any problems with that
one same kind of stuff
yeah so 163 to 166 are all the same sort
of concept there when you move through
them
yeah can we approve that one yeah to ask
so so the thing about having the vice
chair assume the duties of the chair you
confirm conform that with all the
councils that's that's correct it's to
just bring those in
line I um I just want to say that the
New Hampshire Lakes did object to the
change here but I'm just didn't or did
okay on 165 yeah well replacing the uh a
power of the organizations to name
someone I think it's just out of concern
that
there's I should say complete
representation right they are one of the
organizations being that are being
deleted deleted out of the statute yeah
I have a question Mr chair have have has
New Hampshire Lakes been have you had an
nominee we do have one on the council
now okay but it took a while to fill it
did take some time to
fill yeah I I would be
um I would be opposed of just making
that
deletion um but I would I would um offer
if if if it was the um sentiment of the
majority to go to delete that I would
prefer to have it replaced with and one
shall represent an a lake a New
Hampshire lake or Watershed
Association well it does say lakes or
water um I I think we need I mean it
could say one represent New Hampshire
lakes or you could say New Hampshire
Lake Association yes so just a Lake
Association or Watershed Association
would would do just say saying they're
representative New Hampshire Lakes you
could have any have anybody yeah I
see
rers I know so what about what let's
let's start with 164 any problems with
that
one because this is your thing this is
Wastewater Waste
Management are you are you on this
Council no I am not okay I don't fit any
category and they would
[Music]
okay I
mean the the if the deletion of the nrra
I don't know how we could when it's uh
but well it says I don't know
communities which recycle or
recover Solid Waste representing the
public
interest I don't know what I would
replace that with it quarter pass
four I don't know I Mr whims do you can
you think of somebody that would
representative Griffin okay I I'd like
to just make a general comment that this
is the governor's
proposal right she she's the executive
the state she manages the state I'm not
sure that we should be down in the weeds
at the level we're at particularly where
there's little or no Financial impact
I think we have to move on okay and
approve these
sections all right well I mean we could
take a
vote but it it is our responsibility I
mean we are a separate branch of
government I think it is these I think
my my constituents anyim mate would
expect me to review this since it is
presented to us okay all right so on on
Section 164
representative eel moves that we accept
Section 164 second and representative
cell seconds all those in
favor okay good we got
one um
except okay now
165 we had some some
disagreement on the lake one I mean I
think it's I think they were just going
through and removing the names of
organizations without like really study
so I think you could even do that shall
represent New Hampshire River councils
or something like that or just leave
Rivers alone but Lakes I really do I
mean you could have somebody that
represents boers if they're from Lakes
maybe write interests River interests or
lakes
interests they they they like
associations I
guess just say um shall represent New
Hampshire shall represent a New
Hampshire River Association or represent
a New Hampshire Lake Association yeah I
that no the ones that are cross out are
specific organizations they're they're
have bylaws they're you know so I I
think if we make a generic Association
but I think it still need we're all
Association or
Council just keep it generic yeah
generic okay and a Lakes Association
right okay um I'd like to move that we
uh accept
165 subject to the
changes regarding the adding the word
River I mean Association after rivers
and after after LS
yeah okay and probably insert the word a
as appropriate make it grammatically
correct okay do we do we understand what
we're voting on here section 165 are you
seconding this she second represent Rong
second okay all those in favor yes okay
good all right 165
is okay
Melissa what's that Melissa do you want
to um vote on to go back 163 as amended
by the language that we discussed
instead of keeping it as an open item I
thought we didn't quite have language
yet you think we can say renewable
energy member and reduce the public
member to
five okay good all right ready for 163
add the renewable reduce the public
member okay so that's moved by
representative months and second I'll
second it by representative Cals all
those in
favor we're going to add the renewable
member renewable energy somebody
representing renewable energy industry
okay yes because because all these
things are industry one no vote okay
okay one no vote okay
good all right
now down to um accept
see and yeah I mean look at this the
general they they have to submit three
names of which the governor picks one
I'm okay we're okay with this okay rep
representative moves representative cell
seconds yes we accept second it R
section 166 all those in
favor yes okay unanimous okay
accept Okay now
167 a water management Flowage fee so
one 67 and 168 are increasing the annual
registration fee for dams by 10% and
creating a CPI
adjustment uh that will that will be
done every year on on those fees um and
it's doing the same thing for the dam
permitting fees um in 168 and
so that we we'll be we'll be giving you
as part of the or we have given you as
part of that homework assignment you
gave us around fee increases to offset
General funds that's one of the things
that we'll address but this is a so this
is a 10% in order to offset more
positions it would have to be 100% but
that's it's it's something that we
provided as part of consideration but so
that's what those two sections do there
though it's it's a 10%
regular it's a regular CPI adjustment
2027 yes I'm sorry represent a month
when when was the last time that fee was
adjusted
2007 have you looked at what the
inflation's been since then and is that
why you pick the no it's way more than
10% it's it's it's more than 10% I I
think you know this this is something
that that we we express just issues
generally with with fee funds uh to the
governor's office and and you know there
are many agencies going to them with v
increases so I think they had said you
know we're we're willing to do 10% here
um you know but that's so that's that's
kind of where we're
at oh it's not one of the ones on this
paper yeah it's not so so you're this is
the fee you're recommending there's not
a difference so just to be clear on the
there's two matrices the one that has
the hb2 language and changes that's the
10% on the page that we gave you that's
part of the homework assignment you gave
us to say to offset we're not proposing
anything per se but it's it was we asked
for it it was to address it was to
address your your your request so so
does this fee as is bring in 1.3 million
all these
uh you turn on the sorry apologize um
yes um currently they bring in a little
over a million dollars over the
bani okay so where is the one point am I
looking at the right line Dam
registration and permitting fees if we
fee okay it would offset $1.3 million in
general
funds at 10% it adds around
$130,000 or 60,000 a year or $60,000 a
year
I mean in In
fairness the the cost to the agency over
time is more than just inflation I mean
you have Personnel you have benefits you
have all kinds of things so I think
something more than just an inflation
rate
is
appropriate yes representative Le I
would certainly support the inflation
rate but if I'm looking at 167 168 169
you have have the uh cost of living
adjustment based on the Department of
Labor or it successor now in other items
we've had any fee increases subject to
oversight of the fiscal committee
so if these fees are going up to much
you know nationally but maybe not here
in the Hampshire as far as the cost of
living I do think the fiscal committee
should have the final say like we do
with Canon Mountain if they look for an
increase in ticket okay tickets that's a
good
add fiscal committee so so like annually
they could give you the fee schedule and
you would then it would just have to be
reviewed and approved sure because
whoever the successor may be too you
sure sure okay represent R it doesn't
add so um to M to representative
Lehman's point so we would be adding an
addition to this adjustment of review or
it would be contingent on approval by
the fiscal committee yes the annual
increase or by annual or whatever
um I'm throwing this out there but um
one change I would prefer to see on line
12 and in any and where that Clause is
it follows um I'm on page 68 on line 12
where it says shall be
increased I'd prefer to just say shall
be adjusted annually and then by the
percentage change mhm I mean I guess
it's wishful thinking to think that the
might yeah you could you know pigs may
okay yeah was your grandfather in I so I
just wanted to follow up did did you say
a lot of agencies are bringing fee
alteration requests
is my understanding that there are other
agencies bringing I don't know how many
and I don't know in what magnitude I
just know that there are other agencies
bringing up fee requests and so I I
think you
know they this this was a this was a
number that that we worked with them on
um and it's part of the the 10 yeah the
10% was and then you know as part of the
exercise that you gave us we provided
the 100% just to show you what it would
look like if chose to go that row what
if we made it connected to the budget
that is by anually on odd-numbered years
July
1st you could you could certainly do
that um so that instead of every two
yeah instead of every year every two
years yeah yeah I
mean any way you you you want to slice
it I'm not sure that this is uh a
typical uh language in it in other
pieces of statue um but so I think it's
the the world Royster on this one okay
yeah cuz cuz that way it's you're only
doing it half as often but also
connected with coming up with the next
budget you think okay the fees is going
to such and such right and I will say
the one of the points to doing this is
not to have a sticker shock and a big
you know just to maintain yeah but
there's probably not that much no I
agree in a two-year cycle I'm not
worried about that at all that was the
only thing I was going to mention I mean
that you know I I like the Elegance of
what you proposing it's just that
instead of it going up smoothly you're
going to get this ratchet effect okay
all right I'm just trying to make less
work for you know so all right I'll I'll
work on rewriting this uh these various
sections okay
good so
rewrite so these are all fee sections
here okay anything where are we going
from here what's next in the last
section is 169 for us that we believe is
relevant to us is that's the subsurface
which is septic fee increases I should
note that the governor's office um
mentioned that there was a typo in this
section they wanted to do a 10% fee
increase and this is currently a 50% fee
increase um so there there was a typo
there um I will mention that as the
current trajectory is an FY 27 or FY 28
we're we're projecting a um a NE not a
negative balance in in the subsurface
account and so um you know a fee
increase would would be beneficial on on
this is this on your list here or no no
no so it's not on the proposed fee list
because it's not dependent on General
funds um it is on the Matrix that has
the Staple in it um and that's we don't
have any technical changes to that
provision
ni
people and I will add assuming the 50%
for a moment uh that how that was drived
at is Phil can correct me if I'm wrong
the fees hadn't been increased in
statute since 2009 if you applied the
CPI
as you were talking if it had been
applied that's where you end up so this
is not like an expansion of the program
this is basically the program trying to
keep up with the cost of living ETA
which is what we're trying to do but
this is back to my original point about
you have a you have a licensed septic
designer who does a test pit and creates
a septic design and now is going to pay
you an extra
no it's not that expensive yes it is oh
my gosh to do atic to do a septic design
yeah it's well for the for the
right design um depends on the type of
design more typically around
3,000 right okay but still it needs a
very good review I mean this is
right yeah the as the commissioner said
uh the we did look at the CPI since 2009
when the fees were last changed and we
also looked at the construction cost
index which increased also CPI would be
exactly
50% uh to get to to catch up for the
inflation and construction cost index is
more like
70% so we were looking at a way to
rightsize the fees to basically catch up
um with the inflation from where we were
from 2009 and then with the CPI
adjustment year-over-year to to stay
caught up so why isn't this General
funds this is just like any of our other
permits where it's fee for service oh I
see okay and so there's a dedicated fund
or not there's a there's a fund part it
goes into the water resources fund but
this is you know the this is the part of
it relative to subsurface permanence I
see which deals with septic systems and
subdivisions gotcha and our our model on
this indicated that um we will
be um in most recent year we are running
a deficit and sort of a net operating
deficit of
200,000 uh next year we predict about a
million dollar deficit um and you know
by at at that burn rate relative to our
balance we expect to be um negative
balance in FY
27 that's a lot of money
so do you P the employees out of the
water fund oh yeah this this pays for
all of the Personnel costs all the
benefits all of the uh indirect costs
and then
also direct costs so not to jump ahead
but this is the kind of thing we're
thinking about with the solid waste
management fund to have some of the fees
help def Fray the Staffing costs within
that Bureau so it's the same
idea yeah okay
Pro um no we want to maybe change it to
by annual so we're going to wait on this
one okay all right thank you all
gentlemen and
ladies for coming yes represent can I
can I ask one question
um um is there any source of
funding uh
anywhere to assist the the department in
the work it has to do to kind of oversee
closed landfills and and perhaps help
with
remediation yes there there is and and
director whims can can uh speak to that
more
intelligently well I'm not I'm not sure
what the assist commissioner is
referring to I if I understand your
question you're asking is there a source
of funding available to the department
to oversee for to defay its cost for
overseeing closed online landfills yeah
and let me just be more clear I mean you
know there's a landfill gets closed and
there's you know one in my area that you
know director whims and I have talked
about quite a bit um and um while the
the previous operators and maybe the
towns have some responsibility the
department has a pretty significant role
and is there any source of funding to
cover the cost of that the current
source of funding to cover the cost of
that is the general fund the entire
Solid Waste program for New Hampshire
Dees is is General funded there's no
federal money for that there's no
dedicated fund for
it is there any is there any would there
be any way to to to to collect a fee
from maybe the the prior owners the
prior users of the of the um landfill
who are going someplace else now the
majority of those closed online
landfills are municipally owned so if
there were going to be a fee it would
have to be collected from municip IP
alties um I mean we've you know
discussed in Broad terms with this
committee um the concept of a solid
waste disposal search charge which could
absolutely raise funding for that sort
of
thing so so actually the chair just
asked me to mention it in this context
but I think we'll be talking some more
about it um just if since you two are
here here now um I had um presented to
the division with some input from Mr
whim at this concept of the um waste uh
disposal surcharge and the concept that
if we added some money um to into the
solid waste management fund to help
defay employee costs I didn't know if
you wanted to add a little bit more
about that so currently the entire Solid
Waste uh group is on the general fund
and so establishing a search charge on
waste disposed at our landfills would uh
certainly uh allow us to offset that
general fund uh expenditure and free up
General funds for other purposes and so
um I I believe representative eel you
you had mentioned a
$3.50
uh SE charge that that that would allow
us to take the entire uh per ton and
that would that's higher than most other
places no no no it's not oh okay you
missed my presentation I missed your
presentation that would allow that's the
way I remembered it but I could be wrong
us to take the entirety of the program
off of General funds and still have some
funding left over for Grants and and and
the like and whatever we need for for
communities to um provide them some some
funding to do some waste diversion
activities it represent would your the
language of your bill that would cover
monitoring closed landfills and you know
remediation or whatever so so the idea
is that um of course it could be funded
at any level with these discharge fees
but the concept would be that that um
you could take P this is what Mr whims
said you could take 19 people off the
general fund at the
$350 level you could refund all the
money that the New Hampshire
municipalities have paid in back to them
and you could also put about a million
dollars into the grant program so you
could to so to answer your question yes
but we could fund the solid way
uh management Bureau fund our grants and
still make our municipalities whole all
Griffin you're all right so if I
remember the the numbers right there's
something like one one and 3/4 million
tons is that it yeah yes the over the
last five years it's been closer to 2
million on average but last year we saw
a slight decrease because a little bit
less out ofate waste was brought in so
it was about 1.75 million ton last year
so are we not concerned that if we put a
fee on it the out of state waste will
get even smaller because they'll they
have some alternative I I'm not sure
that that that I would use the word
concern it's possible that could happen
that would make a lot of people very
happy um a lot of members of the
legislature I believe would be very well
but I mean if we if we're counting on
this money to create job just pay for
jobs then you know again the the the way
the numbers work if you look at that
$33.50 proposed T ton tonage fee on um
at the last year's low at 1.75 million
ton that's about $6.1 million that would
absolutely per per year so that would
absolutely cover the roughly $3 million
operating budget for the entire program
so all positions all C everything State
grant program associated with landfills
all that um it would provide uh we think
it's hard a little bit hard to estimate
but we think the the the amount that
would be needed as the language in the
bill provides um for uh providing
payments back to municipalities to sort
of make them whole for what they've paid
for that search charge fee would be
between one and two million so even if
it's at the outside even if it's at 2
million it would still leave a million
dollars uh so you only got 3 million 2
million and then that to get to 6 you'd
have $1.1 million for making grants to
municipalities businesses any others
anybody who proposes to advance
technology and a facility that would
help um divert waste from disposal so as
we had some discussion last time the
hope would be that the fee would
actually drive certain policy goals and
that in fact you might collect less over
time um but that wouldn't necessarily
are you currently have some kind of
grant program like this or not yeah we
funded it we oh okay right it it it's
been funded one with one general fund
appropriation to date I understand
representative Griffin yeah is all that
Tage out of state no sir uh the LA like
last year for example um one about 1.1
million ton was inate waste in generated
waste and 670,000 ton were out of state
more typically it's on the order of
about a million and a million it's about
5050 well is is any of that instate
waste coming from municipalities yes and
and the way that the yes so this is
orties no no that's the I'm so that's
the point when we constructed this
before the money that the municipalities
are paying will be refunded to
them but and you retain the I mean we
can talk about it more but you retain
the rest of it within the fund because
we don't want to this is to help
municipalities and not to hurt them well
but if municipalities are 1.1 oh but
some of them are are businesses they're
not Municipal health I I can clarify if
it with theit's permission so of that
one if we say in round numbers if that 1
million ton um that's in state generated
waste we and again we're estimating
because we never kind of parse this out
but we believe we have pretty good
information that suggest that no more
than 50% of that is waste that was paid
to be disposed of by Municipal by
Municipal governments and the language
in the in the proposal would uh
basically allow them to itemize to us
how much they spent in a given year and
we would refund all that back to them
and that's that $2 million figure that
when I broke down the6 million that's
what the $2 million was so 3 million to
cover operating costs 2 million back to
the municipalities to kind essentially
make them whole and then another million
available for Grants I see all right
yes
right well
um so I did I went to ncsl and I had
them do a do a survey and the the search
charges are all over the map um I think
the thing is that there are an awful lot
of State states that you'll see on that
list that have other sources of funds
more than than we do so that's one thing
but I think you also have to look at it
from a regional standpoint so we talked
about this um when I was talking about
the bill Maine has a state
run um landfill and so if they're
charging money it's basically charging
money to help run their state fund their
you know Vermont has a $6 landfill I
mean uh I'm sorry we've been up for
hours forever a $6 per ton search charge
that they have had for a really really
long time Massachusetts has a mechanism
where they uh use waste to energy uh
credits of some sort to fund a
multi-million dollar grant program we
wouldn't do that but but main I mean
Massachusetts only has like one landfill
and a couple of waste of energy plants
and
costs per for disposal are so much
higher than ours I don't think they're
going to be running away too much if we
add three bucks to a ton I mean the real
costs here are Transportation costs and
not so much tipping fees um they're
either railing it out or you know I
think during my original presentation I
said the town of New London for instance
to go from Bristol to Success New
Hampshire is almost $700 a hopper load
so we
really outliers in not having some sort
of um search charge to help defay the
burden of solid waste in our state okay
so um Melissa if we want to work on any
of the new bills we got we have to put
it in the calendar or not yep I have
that as an item to discuss with you
after but if you want to I was um we I
think we got um seven new
bills assigned to division one so maybe
put those for next Friday so I don't
know if you want to yes if you y cuz
that's the soonest we could do I was
thinking okay all right so my goal is to
try to get through everything in house
build too on Monday and Tuesday if
possible um and then we can we have
Wednesday we have our public hearing and
then Friday maybe these bills and real
budget stuff right so
yeah you think we can do that that yes
rep yes uh commissioner just just for
clarification first of all you all been
very patient because we have so much
here I appreciate that so what is your
your your thought on what we want to
make sure we're available to discuss the
homework assignment the fees yeah
um yeah well that would be a new thing
right so that's
probably either late Friday or or next
week right I don't know if there's much
time next week but yeah yeah might be
the following week yeah I think we're
going to have to have I think we can get
through hb2 this week of the items that
are in hb2 we're going to need a whole
another separate discussion on what are
we adding to hbt so we're compiling some
of those in the background this can be
one of them we have fees from other
agencies as well so I figure we kind of
look at those as a packet all together
and then decide on that not next week
but the week after right all right we
will see everybody on 10 o'clock on
Monday thank you